if you look at my YouTube career I
wasn't super talented there's not a lot
of entertainment on the videos um
they're not coming for my dashing good
looks the only thing I did was I just
kept going most people quit I just kept
going but most people don't have that
stubbornness consistency for anything
like you are what you consistently do if
you eat one chocolate bar you're fine if
you eat a chocolate bar every meal
you're going to be kind of screwed over
tie yourself Worth to the effort you're
putting in on releasing whatever the
thing is like if you're you want to be
great at podcasting if you did a podcast
cast a month how many years does it take
to catch up to 365 it's like it's never
going to happen whatever goals you have
when you take consistent action you're
going to
win what are some steps that you think
people should take or can take uh to get
that momentum to add more of that to
their life I think it starts with
identifying where do you lack right like
what do you want to get better at so for
you it's like hey I want to be a better
entrepreneur I don't have business
people in my life so I'm going to make
an effort to be around people who are
more successful at that thing so if you
have a health goal or relationship goal
business goal they don't it's not that
you have to hang on Elon Musk to get it
right I mean there's lots of people
who've done it if if it's a relationship
goal who are the happiest couples that
you know and try to spend more time with
them or health goal who are the people
who are running you know or or just
working out on their own and how do you
spend more time with them when you're in
that Circle you'll just do a lot more so
what is the thing that you are lacking
um and then I would split that between
uh moments like an event or conference
or hanging out with somebody and then
what can you do consistently on The
Daily right so what ends up happening is
you get really motivated you go to a
conference you meet some people you
learn and it takes you to another level
but then it's easy to fall back down to
you know where you were like Oh I
thought I could I thought I could write
a book like I can't write a book I'm not
going to start a show I can't what where
did I think I could do that from because
you've been taken out of the environment
put back into your current environment
so it's hard harder to to get going
again not impossible but just harder but
I love those moments because it shows
what's possible and I'm a big believer
that the ideas that come to you when
you're feeling bold powerful confident
courageous are actually the right ones
for you like those are your best ideas
and then your head talks you down from
doing them because it doesn't it only
understands a world that currently
exists like well you didn't go to school
for this what you're going to be an
entrepreneur you can't be an
entrepreneur right like the head starts
to take over so those ideas that came to
you when you're at that conference
around these people like those are
actually the right ones for you and you
need to then inject new things daily to
remind yourself of the person you want
to be so that's why I have things like
my YouTube channel right because I need
a daily because I want to be around uh I
want to be on Oprah Winfrey and Steve
Jobs and Elon Musk and Bill Gates and
these people every day that when I'm
watching their video it makes me want to
go and do more what do you think is the
best part about being an entrepreneur
and what's the scariest part if you had
the kind of worn would be entrepreneurs
out
there I think the reason you get into
entrepreneurship uh has to has to be
strong that you're moving towards
something not away from something hating
your job is not a good enough reason uh
having a bad boss is not a good enough
reason having toxic people around you in
your workplace means you should get out
of that but that's not the reason that
go be an entrepreneur because you're
going to work harder as an entrepreneur
than you will yes job
right now now you're you get yes you get
to set the rules and you get to decide
what you want to do but if if you're
only in it because of Freedom that's the
wrong reason you have to be in it
because you want to make an impact you
have to want to serve I I believe that
humans are built to serve I think it's
in all of us I think it's hardwired into
into us uh and that how do you serve
well your purpose comes from your pain
that the thing that you struggled with
the most in life whatever the most
painful moment of your life was helping
other people will not go through the
same thing that you went through will be
the thing that will fill you up for life
and will never get old and so that's the
thing that people need to find I love
helping entrepreneurs because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur so
I want to I want to now pay it forward
and help others and that's that's
everybody so you need to figure out
what's the what's the going to that
you're you're creating not the moving
away from and then how you going to
serve and if you if you do that you'll
have success I think most entrepreneurs
when they get started they're doing it
for their wrong reasons because they
just don't like their job and then
they're just chasing an
opportunity they don't actually love the
thing but this is a hot thing to do in
2019 2020 2021 so that's what I'm going
to do but if you don't love that thing
you're going to lose um so that's the
the biggest mistake most entrepreneurs
make what advice would you give to this
person to kind of I don't know if it's
like to shake things up in their world
or just to give them momentum wow so
there's a lot there uh I would want to
know more about the individual but some
generic advice one I would expect to
suck at the start I would expect a
struggle at the start I think people
expect to be amazing at the start and
then they're shocked by how hard it is
when they actually get out and go uh
this certainly my case I expected to be
doing way better than I I was at the
beginning and I was actually too
embarrassed to tell my friends and too
ashamed that like I was making no money
and I couldn't come out to dinner or
birthday parties not because I was too
busy but because that 20 bucks was too
much for me to go out for a night so
expect to suck at the start um I think
remembering your why remembering what
you're doing remember the big ambition
that you have I think if you started a
business just to try to make money you
will fail because it's going to get hard
and it's a deep passion for what you do
that helps you through those tough times
that you would keep doing it even if you
weren't making any money because you
just love it someone it's a it's a part
of you what what this is is a part of
you you have to keep doing it if you
stop it a piece of you dies you like
that's what you need to find and so
making money is important too but it's
never number one there's got to be
something more important if you only did
it to make money you're going to fail
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there perfectionism is really just fear
you know you're just afraid right so I
try I mean of course I'm still afraid of
many things but if I can catch it I try
not to be or do the thing that makes me
scared but to the Kill Your Darlings um
yeah one of my greatest fears earlier
on uh in my career
was being an aing rock star and so one
of the things that for some reason
really bothered me was you look at these
rock stars who were big in like the 70s
or 80s or 90s or whatever and they still
go on tour and like wow they're still on
tour like it's amazing that they're
still on tour but they're still singing
the songs they were singing like decades
ago yes you know like where is the new
stuff like have you had nothing new to
say in 30 years since you recorded the
thing right and right anytime you're
anytime you're uh judgmental of somebody
else it's self-reflection it's like it's
your own your worried about yourself not
about like Aeros Smith or whatever
doesn't care about me or my opinion and
I don't really hate on Aeros so it's
like if you are criticizing somebody
else it's like we look inside because
you have that same thing that you're
criticizing and I realized it was my
fear that I I don't want to be that like
I don't want to be Evan uh you know 30
years later still making videos yay but
like telling the war stories of back in
2023 when you know on with Sean talking
about Tom Brady uh I want to make new
stuff right I want to make new stuff and
I think I've I've overcome that one um I
only bring up the past when people ask
me questions about um about the past uh
but that was yeah that was a big thing
that was a big fear of mine early on
getting started it's like I didn't want
to just hold on to my darlings and sing
the same songs over and over and over
again the more that you can make choices
that build self-respect and build
character the more you're capable of
making more choices like that people
think of it as some giant thing like
whatever your goals are I talk to a lot
of entrepreneurs so they want to start
their business but whatever your goals
are your personal your health goals your
Fitness your relationship your business
goals whatever they are it's not just
some one thing one giant goal that you
chase it's the daily minor decisions
that you have to make it's every day you
have this choice to am I going to do the
thing I said I was going to do or am I
going to not do it you know like am I
going to let myself down again here or
am I going to do the thing that makes me
proud and it's in in these minor
decisions that we have every day that
ultimately leads to you building your
character so when you started your show
it's great amazing a lot of people would
love to start a show like you did a lot
of people would love to have guests on
their show as well and they immediately
had that insecurity in their head come
to say well who's going to listen to me
and what am I going to talk about and
which guest is going to want to come on
my show and they've been on other shows
how am I better how am I different and
what that does is shut down
your action to go and create the show
and the more you listen to that voice
the the less action you do and the more
you teach yourself that you suck do it
you're training yourself to not do it
again the next time and not do it it
because this becomes your identity like
I'm the person who has great ideas but
never follows through and that is
something that we have to start to
consciously destroy on the health
Journey well I'm just a fat person and I
can't stick to a diet and I can't do
anything I can't run more than a mile I
can't like and we've created this
identity but all of those things are
fixable but it's not one giant leap
right you don't just get healthy by
going to the gym one day it's the
everyday consistency that you train
yourself for I'm writing a new book
about finding your purpose and turn into
a business and then I included the last
chapter on how to make money because I
think a lot of people feel icky
or nasty about trying to well I just
love helping these people so I can't
charge for this I think it actually is
selfish not to charge for it I think it
becomes your your obligation that you
have to charge for it not to everybody I
think you there'll always be a
percentage if it's 10% or 20% of people
who who get in for free because they
can't afford it but if you don't learn
how to make money from your purpose then
it will always be a hobby and you'll
always have to do a full-time job to
then support your hobby where if you
actually made it a business and learned
how to make money using doing it serving
people in an ethical you know
life-changing positive way then you can
reach more people you can build a team
you can scale up now instead of as maybe
as a hobby you can hit 10 women a month
W hobby but if you have a business and
now you're you're building a team of
amazing women who all want the same
thing maybe now you're reaching millions
of women so I think it I think it's your
responsibility to to turn that into
something that then can create a ripple
effect greater than just a hobby on the
side how you can model success this is
what saved my business when I wanted to
quit at my company my first software
company and then I realized that you
know what I'm not the first guy to try
to sell software before like somebody
has figured this
out if I just learn from that person I
can apply those strategies to my
business and so I modeled Bill Gates who
started Microsoft and I've never met
Bill Gates but he saved my company and I
looked at this strategies of how did he
start Microsoft not how does Microsoft
grow now who cares it's a huge company
but like start how did he start zero to
one that's what I wanted to do and I
modeled him and I applied that to my
business and we started to grow and so
whatever dreams whatever goals whatever
business you have somebody's already
figured it out may not be exactly what
you want to do and that's good because
you're different you're an entrepreneur
you're gonna put your own twist on it
but people have already figured it out
and so understanding what they did and
trying to break down their success could
be really helpful so that if you're
hustling and grinding you're spending
your time on the right things that will
help you as opposed to the things that
aren't leading to
success so so when you say model after
them you you mean like you don't
necessarily have to meet this person you
can just read their books or watch their
interviews as that how you learned from
from Bill Gates for example yeah so
there's two kinds of mentors there's the
regular mentors that people think about
where you go for coffee and they're you
know they're local you can go meet them
and they break down your business uh and
I never had that right like my parents
taught me so much about life and being a
human being but never about business and
nobody in my family was an entrepreneur
and so I had nobody to go and have
coffee with I went to my banker and said
hey can you help me with my business and
like well do you need a loan like no I
don't know do I need a loan I don't know
he's like yeah you're not really in the
right place like I didn't know anybody
and so I Look To What I Call
aspirational mentors these the people
who you aspire to be like or aspire to
learn from and some people may have
already passed on and you'll never meet
them like I have Steve Jobs up on my
wall I'm never going to meet him
obviously um and a lot of people behind
me uh some I may meet one day or some
have passed on uh and so I would look at
two kinds of what I call aspirational
mentors the first are in your industry
whatever you want to do somebody has
done it you want to be a successful
YouTuber there's lots of people who've
done it Go and model them see what they
did the more uh successful they are the
more information there is on them
whether it's interviews or books or
magazine articles like their story is
somewhere and again look to how they got
started as opposed to what they're doing
now because it's a different scale and
then the second kind are just the people
who you look up to you know if if I love
Oprah Winfrey I can learn something from
her even if I don't want to have my own
talk show you know if you love Michael
Jordan you could learn from him even if
you never want to be a basketball player
like the way that he works and his
hustle and effort he's in the gym you
can apply that to your life and to your
business even if you never go on to try
to become an NBA player so those two
things the people who have done what you
want to do maybe you hate them but you
can still learn from their success
rather and just do it your way and then
the people who you just really look up
to and really admire and say one day I
want to have that kind of impact again
understanding how they got started and
modeling their success to help you get
your breakthrough I think everybody can
can lean in and learn whatever they want
to learn um I had the Good Fortune of
having some great parents on they're on
the wall behind me year and eight or N9
years old and those are my parents there
and they would always tell me hey you
everything TR carich like you do
anything you believe that you can and so
they helped instill that in me um I
think the whole you know to Gary Vee's
point about are you born with it well
what were you doing at 7 years old like
were you doing lemonade stains and
garage sales and taking some initiative
um but if you weren't don't feel like oh
my gosh now I can't be an entrepreneur
it's it's so much easier now than ever
to start your own business or to lean in
on the thing for sure like I believe
everybody's got Michael Jordan level
genius at something like you're the
greatest in the world at something and
you just don't believe that you are and
you don't believe in your dreams enough
to go chase them down but you can
whether it's being an entrepreneur and
believing in your business whether it's
believing in your health Journey that is
possible whether it's you know climbing
Mount kill andero or losing 100 pounds
or like whatever the thing is that you'd
love to do it's it's possible people
like you have done it and that's where a
lot of people get stuck is like well
it's possible like somebody else has
done it but I can't do it because I'm
whatever and my story early with the
YouTube stuff was um I'm an introvert
I'm shy so I'm I'm not going to make it
you know but I'll keep making content
because I'm serving but I'm I'm never
going to be the big name because I'm too
introverted and too shy and I still am
by the way it just doesn't come out when
I'm doing shows like this um but you can
you know you can whatever whatever that
story is in your head it's totally
fixable and other people you know like
you have done it and it just comes down
to starting to change what you put into
your head I think that's the biggest
thing of all it's why I make so much
content
because if somebody felt like their
health Journey was impossible you know
it's like you know J you don't
understand was impossible you know it's
like you know J you don't understand
I've been like this and my family has
been like this and it's just not
possible and I've tried a million things
and just nothing works and it's it's
never going to happen Jay just that's
that's who I am right if they spent a
month with you you know because you're
more confident in their ability to get
healthy than they are and their
inability to get
healthy and same thing with me if
somebody's hanging out with me for an
extented period of time if we were
hanging out together uh I'm going to get
a lot healthier
probably and you're going to be making
more YouTube videos man we're going to
get you on there and and crushing it
because whoever is more confident wins
and so the problem is we're surrounded
by people who don't believe in our
dreams who tell us that it's not
possible and we're also feeding our mind
with things that keep us stuck where we
are and if you want to change something
it's totally possible but it starts with
actually changing um that environment so
that you have a you have the crutch like
to get going to get you out of the
Starting Gate do you feel like some
people are just that entrepreneurs are
born I know you say that everybody has
it enough to serve but you think there's
some people that are just more prone or
um more gifted or more capable when it
comes to um achieving
entrepreneurship so I think I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level Talent at something okay uh if you
go religious you know everybody's a
child of God you were created you are
beautiful you should be making something
amazing in the world you are not meant
to be living this small life right so if
everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something for some people
that's being an entrepreneur for others
it might be being a teacher in the
school right it could be many things how
do you find it well you need to
explore you need to taste you need to
test you know just like you found my
videos you were searching for motivation
and you found them and then you he like
I like this and then you dop into it a
lot of times you can't think your way
through these things because chances are
the thing that you should be doing is
very diff than what is in your family
and in your circle most of the time the
thing that you should be doing with your
life is very different than what your
parents did or what your brothers or
sisters or cousins or Community or
church people that are doing yeah and so
it takes courage to go off and do it
right if if you're if you're working
with women who have a belief system of
well women are supposed to be this way
but then they know that like I don't
want to be that I'm I'm greater than
that I know I'm greater than that right
yeah to have the courage to chase that
stream down I think is important and
that's where I think people like you are
a voice there are things that are
triggers for me now like three words
scary difficult hard if I say those
think those write those I have to go do
that
thing because I want to all together a
one at a time any of them like if I said
if you said hey Evan you should you
should go do X and I said oh that that's
really hard okay now I got to do it
because I don't want to accept hard as a
reason to not do
right um hence hence the Dorito bags
yeah like the Dorito the Dorito is a
crazy that there are some things with me
that are easy to connect with like
introverted shy humble Canadian whatever
um and there are others that are more
difficult to connect with so the Doritos
bag is one of the more challenging
things to to connect with because that's
more of a hard push where when you're on
a diet the usual strategy is get rid of
the food get rid of junk food from your
house that's what people always say and
and I think that's a good first step but
it's you're basically walking on
crutches so when you break your leg you
use crutches yes awesome but your goal
is to be able to to walk and to run and
to live a normal life so if you can only
win when you're in your perfect
environment well what happens when you
go on a cruise or office party or
vacation you're just pounding back the
food if I'm scared to come and do this
show right and like oh my gosh pyan I
hope she cancels on me what am I going
to answer I nervous right and and I and
my feel my heart B so scary difficult
heart is one the other is I have a boom
boom boom test which is if my heart is
beaten out of my chest that's a physical
manifestation of scary difficult hard
which means I have to go do that thing
too so if I'm if I'm I used to want
people to cancel on me like if I saw you
I'd say yes in two months we'll do this
thing but then I'd see like oh my God
Patty and today I hope she cancels I
don't want to disappoint her this is
going to be terrible boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom physical sign I have to
go off and do it even if I showed up and
and vomited all over my microphone and
the camera because I was so nervous I
would still mentally reward myself to
say you did the hard thing you have to
do the work that you don't see as work
uh Jerry Seinfeld calls it the torture
that you can endure it's like for a lot
of people what you're doing St up to
three: in the morning just to do a
YouTube Interview people are like dude
that's crazy that's torture I would
never do that right for people jumping
into my schedule like to make three
YouTube videos every day they would
think that that's tortured for me it's
fun I enjoy the process if you only have
a goal and you don't like the process
you'll never hit that goal yeah you have
to enjoy the actual work like if you're
GNA interview people you have to enjoy
interviewing people if you don't you're
never gonna have a good interview
Channel like other guys who love that
will crush you and so if you're just
started out I think people easily get
tricked into looking at what are the
hottest Industries for this year here
and what's the next big opportunity
let's go all in on bitcoin meanwhile you
know nothing about Bitcoin yeah you know
and then that's that's the fastest way
to lose your money so you have to do the
thing that you love whoever it is that
you look up to like who's who's done the
thing that you want to do if you love
Kanye if you love Steve Jobs or Elon
Musk or Oprah or whoever it is that you
look up to look at their story look at
how they got started it'll do two things
for you one it'll it'll give you the
tactics like what did this person do to
become successful and two it'll give you
the motivation because chances are the
people who you look up to started off
with a lot less than what you currently
have right now uh one of the people I
love looking up to is Oprah she you know
was a sexually abused growing up she
didn't grow up with her parents uh her
grandmother raised her she was so poor
that she her grandmother bought bags of
potatoes and used the potatoes to then
sew it into a dress and Oprah went to
school in potato bags it's like just
imagine showing up in school in a potato
bag as a dress you it's it's crazy and
so it's hard to imagine that whatever
situation you think is so terrible in
your life right now that Oprah had it
you know way worse than what you're
going through and look at what she was
able to do and so people have done it so
getting out of the excuses in your head
of why re what resources you feel you
don't have or what circumstances life is
thrown against you people with a lot
less of than a lot more and so model
their success and go after it believing
in ourselves is being true to ourselves
we're not changing Who We Are to serve
others we're serving others as we are
right and that's critical the
authenticity the
genuiness how how did you segue that to
salsa dancing so I never learned to
dance growing up I always felt kind of
awkward at a club or whatever dancing
and uh in University I decided okay I'm
gonna I want to learn how to dance and
so there was a there was a ballroom
class that I took with my then
girlfriend not Nina um and we signed up
and took the class and she never really
liked it uh we went couple lessons maybe
a semester and then she didn't want to
do it anymore and it was a kind of class
where you you have to go with a partner
and so I didn't have a partner and I
didn't want to ask another girl to be my
partner when I'm in a Rel it didn't feel
right You' be get in a lot of trouble
doing that Evan Ju Just saying yeah yeah
so it's okay so that's the end of that
whatever fine you know there's other
things to do but then when we ended up
breaking up one of the things I said was
well I can go dancing again like why
don't I go learn some dancing and salsa
dancing is the easiest dance to be able
to pick up as a solo person so what I
mean by that is when you're dancing it's
part of the culture to switch Partners
all the time so even if you come as a
married couple it would still be normal
to dance with other guys for you and
other women for me which is part of the
cult now some people stay together but
for the most part the culture is very
interchangeable
it's part of the energy I would imagine
yes and borom is very specific it's like
you got your One partner Sala is more of
a street dance and I just fell in love
with it now on paper I'm Too Tall I take
big steps I don't speak Spanish I didn't
learn this growing up uh you know all of
the things that we could say are logical
reasons why you shouldn't do it and I
think a lot of us live in the world of
well I I can't do that and I shouldn't
do that without ever even trying and I
wasn't even very good at the beginning
either because a lot of those reasons
but I just loved it you know there's
something about like this is amazing I
had to I I signed up for two different
schools to go learn because I was a slow
learner at it but just to pick it up and
and I love meeting people I love the
connection I love I love I think also
learning a new skill that you thought
was too difficult also is how you build
belief in yourself to say oh I couldn't
I can't do that but then you see that
you can raises your belief level to do
other things so that made me a better
entrepreneur how could someone like take
their business and evolve it with them
what kind of things could they
do just think about what is it that you
want to create so for example I had a
successful website it was off my name we
had lots of successful people writing
for it um making money off advertising
coming to the site I was getting
restless and so I said I'm going to try
something new I'm GNA I want to go to
YouTube I'm going to try that and I
tried a whole bunch of stuff like you
try things don't know at the beginning
it was going to work out or not so I
tried YouTube as one of many things and
I liked it and so I kept doing it and
then they kept doing it and I evolved my
business a lot of people don't even know
me from my website they only know me
from my YouTube channel yeah right
because we we've blown up there but if I
get bored of YouTube like the minute
that like I like talking to you this is
great Michael Michael's doing an
interview I love it let's get on board
the minute this feels like work like
it's oh man I got to talk you got to do
another interview this sucks I I need to
quit I need to do something else because
you will never win doing work that you
hate okay and so the minute that this
feels like a job I need to stop and go
off and do something else what is it
something else you know like just ask
yourself what what what would I do what
do I want to do what do I want to work
on yeah you may not have the perfect
vision yet for like the final goal but
find some small thing to get started on
share with us some of your tips for
creating super
yeah I think it starts with figuring out
what is your message what do you stand
for what's what's the one word that
defines you it's it's what I talk about
my first book but what why should I
follow
you like for me I'm about believe so if
you want a shot in the arm of believe
you want to believe in yourself more
you're going to enjoy everything that I
put out you're going to enjoy this
interview you're G to enjoy my YouTube
videos you're going to enjoy my my upand
cominging IG account you're going to
enjoy all that stuff if you don't like
leave you're not going to like me you're
not you're going to tune out you've
already shut off this podcast you know
you don't you're not going to like what
I have to say and so it's figuring out
what is your message what is so
important and different about you like
why are you doing the thing that you're
doing and then people who like that
message will follow
along most people don't have a message
that they really believe in most people
are just trying to be like somebody
else and that's hard to get like why am
I going to be your Super Fan I'm going
to be that person's Super Fan you're
trying to just be like Logan I'm going
to follow Logan why am I going to follow
you what's so different and so it's
figuring out what that thing is that's
different about you what your message is
that's super clear and so that I think
whenever I need an injection of like if
you're Mr inspiration whenever I need
inspiration or whenever I need energy
like I'm gonna come you to you I'm gonna
listen to your podcast otherwise what's
the reason if I can't if I can't tell
somebody why they need to listen to your
podcast or buy your book or check out
your Channel
then you're sunk like you need people
talking about you and the message that
you have um now not every message is a
positive one you know some people make
their name off of tabloids and making
fun of people and that's that's that's
escapism so it's either like people want
to either escape the life that they hate
or they want to go and build a better
life for themselves so you're either
playing on the comedy or on the making
fun of somebody else it's all escaping
the life that you don't have to think
about your life you don't have to think
about growth you just want to shut off
your brain and be entertained or you
want to solve the problems and you want
to build a better life and so that's
where you get the inspiration and the
motivation and practical uh content so
just figuring out where you lie on that
path and then being consistent about it
that's why the journey is important too
like if you're saying hey I love I'm
about inspiration I want to inspire
people and everything I do I want to be
an inspiration so I have my clothing
line and I have my books I have my
foundation and I'm starting my podcast
and if you want to be inspired listen to
my podcast every week and then even when
you're booking guests
right you're booking guests who are
going to inspire people right so like
once you get that identity down then it
makes every decision a lot easier and
you give super fans you give fans a
reason to subscribe and then become
super fans the point of the podcast is
to help people be unstuck if it's in
relationships if it's in business if
it's in the idea that they've always had
that they want to do something they want
to achieve it's to unlock that potential
cool so you're in a fortunate position
in that you you're starting it from
scratch but you're not you're not
starting from scratch right you you have
you have some contacts in the industry
you know some people you you can pull
sweaters is a analogy an old Mentor used
to give me uh okay where like you're
pulling sweaters to get to the head of
the line sure where you know enough
people that you can get to people and
you can get to bigger and bigger and
bigger people right so you know there's
people who've used your service you've
gone to events you have connections even
you know after this interview goes up
you can see who follows me and easy hack
is like for current guests see who who
follows them on Instagram and then reach
out to them oh so after this interview
goes live see who follows me on
Instagram and then you can reach out to
them and say hey I had EV kacel on my
show I'd love to have you on too wow my
name May mean nothing to many people but
it means something to a few people it
allows you to do you know Outreach okay
but so you can you can work your way up
and you can get you can get guests on
your show at a faster clip than most
people who are just tur off a podcast
cool to what end like how can I bring
you value how can other people come on
and bring Justin value audience value
because that's I guess the work of the
uh that's the brand like what what are
we trying to create here so unlimited
potential okay awesome I love it I mean
I'm all believe so great I love it is it
the guest is it the format is it people
coming on and coaching you is it like
what are we going to do different on
this podcast compared to all the other
podcasts out there that you know have
the same purpose as you you don't have
to have it all figured out either on
this on this call right now but that
becomes the uh the ongoing fact why
would somebody subscribe to the channel
why would they watch what you're doing
you can get guests which is again you
you're not St from scratch but if I'm
coming on your show how does this become
a different interview or show than the
other ones that that other people are on
that I've gone on other people's
channels
had you know similar conversations I
mean I talk about belief in potential
all the time so how does it become
different is it about my potential story
is it about your potential story is it
about diving into a specific like and it
all comes from your heart like what do
you actually want to create I don't
enjoy being the center of attention it
doesn't it doesn't um it doesn't do
anything for me but where it started to
shift was well I still want to serve you
know like I still want to feel like what
I do matters to people and that I wake
up and I'm having a meaningful impact
and so whereas I've had to learn to
harness the power of the introvert and
and figure this stuff out as I go but
also learn from other introverts and
that okay so I don't like networking
meetings I hate small talk I don't talk
to the guy next to me on the airplane I
all of that stuff but but I love
meaningful conversations and I can get
like I see Patty and in my calendar like
this is g to be amazing let's go
and so how how do how do you show up
with that energy well I don't know I'm
not I think introverts still want to
serve introverts still want to have
meaningful connections introverts still
want to feel like what they do matters
and the more I can tap into that then
then my energy and enthusiasm that is in
everybody um comes out so it's just it
was but that's that was years of I wish
I knew you 10 years ago like things
would have been so much better have you
had those kind of uh
battles in your journey yeah I had one
big one and and after that I didn't have
it again uh and that was when I was 19
when I was trying to make that decision
do I I had all I wanted to do up to that
point was I wanted to be a banker right
that's my dream and I'm in my last year
university and I have opportunities to
work at um Merl Lynch and McKenzie was a
strategic consulting company and they
fly me to New York and put up in the
wall of ptor and like wine and dine and
all this stuff to kind of recruit me to
try to join their company and it was the
job that I always wanted the job the job
man I'm talking 80 to
100,000 first year coming out of
University 19 years old traveling the
world doing mergers and Acquisitions
like what I wanted meanwhile I've got
this
company that's sucking I'm making 300
bucks a month and it was just something
like I don't I don't know what to to do
yeah it's confus uh and my parents
actually were were very supportive and
and said you know what whatever you do
will support you you know they always
told me that I was a cast carmichel my
mom's last name is cast my middle name
is cast I'm a cast carmichel I can do
anything that I wanted uh but my friends
they were all jealous they're like what
how are you not how are you even
thinking about this right how are you
not just saying yes to these job
opportunities uh and I was really torn I
didn't know I wanted to do I didn't know
which path to go in and then the thing
that helped me and the thing that I
still use today whenever I'm faced with
this kind of decision is I think about
not regretting my
decisions and I fast forward to life at
90 or however old I am when I'm like
dying on my deathbed and thinking back
will I regret having said yes or no to
this decision and I could live with
saying no to the job because I knew I
could get another job right but I
couldn't live with giving up on the com
because I didn't know if it would come
by again and so I gave I said I'll give
myself a year I'll give myself a year
I'm going to try this company and see
how if I can make a take off and if it
doesn't it go back into the job market
and just that idea of not trying to live
with regret is then that it was super
difficult at that point like hardest
decision ever to make in my life but
ever since then I just I just think
about it this thing that I'm thinking
about doing now this impossible decision
am I going to regret not doing it
and then that makes the decision easy
then I have to go out and do it make
today
count uh I try to go into every day
thinking I want to make something today
that my grandkids are going to be proud
of so like this interview with Michael I
want my grandkids to see it I want to
tell my grandkids a story about this
crazy guy Michael who stayed up till 3
in the morning to interview me and now
he's off with Grant Cardone as his
business partner running all of these
multi-billion dollar real estate
Investments like I want to I wna I want
to make make today count and I think
it's so easy to put something off till
tomorrow or the next week like that's a
great idea that I learned from Michael
I'll do that tomorrow and then it
becomes the next day we we think we have
so much time and then you look back it's
like where did the past five years go
like it just what happened I wanted to
do all these things and nothing has
happened yet and so again if you
approached every day with the mindset of
today I'm G to make something that's
going to count I'm gonna make something
that I want my grandkids to see and
again if you take that approach every
day you're gonna make some amazing
things of the next year we all want to
wake up and feel like what we do matters
if you woke up and you felt every day
that you don't matter to somebody else
but the work you do is meaningless it
doesn't matter that's the path down to
anxiety stress depression suicides where
a lot of people a lot of people wake up
and feel like just today's doesn't
matter nobody cares if I show up or
not but on the other hand if you felt
like today's going to matter today it
it'll mean something I'm going to make
something I'm going to show up for
somebody it's going to touch maybe not a
million lives but like one person's life
if you're going to show up and you're
going to take your mom to brunch and
it's going to touch her life it's like
I'm excited to show for today right and
so we all want to feel like the work
that we do
matters the people will love helping the
most are the people who currently are
who we used to be so when I said your
purpose comes from your pain whatever
you struggled through that made you feel
like The Biggest Loser of all time is
now what you want to help other people
through cuz there's lots of people right
now who feel like that loser and they'll
learn from you in a way that they won't
learn from me or Eddie or Oprah or
somebody else cuz you have a different
story and so we all you know helping and
serving is hardwired into our brains you
know it's the same they did functional
MRIs on people's brains and found the
same part of the brain lights up when
you're serving or helping as when you're
having food and having sex so it's like
it we We crave the desire to want to
help people but there's a difference
between
just helping somebody cross the street
or holding the door for somebody or
buying the coffee like these little acts
of kindness
versus when you see somebody who's like
you and you help them overcome something
that then years later like when Eddie
says five years ago I don't know when I
talked to you haven't picked up the
phone and called me and how much of a
difference it made right that's that's
the stuff that makes me feel I don't
even remember I don't remember talking
to
any I'll show you the email you'll get a
kick out of it St you
I mean I remember you outside the
bathroom
so but like that those are the kind of
things that feel really good it makes me
want to keep doing it right that Eddie
said hey you took a chance on me and
gave me half an hour of your time or
however long we talked when I was just
getting started I mean I do that for a
ton of people who also don't go anywhere
right is it so it's not like it's great
to have a success story but not
everybody turns out to be an Eddie as
well uh but that becomes proof that I
should keep doing it makes me feel feel
good right you stopping me outside the
bathroom leading to this you know we
have a good conversation it makes me
want to say yes to the next guy if it's
a total you know like a disaster and we
the building's locked and his
microphone's not set up and like oh
maybe I don't say yes to the next guy I
don't know
right so but we all want to feel like
the work we do matters isn't important
to people and every time we feel that it
does so much more for our soul than just
holding the door for somebody or doing a
random act of kindness as a Creator we
tend to kind of compare ourselves to
other others and and lose the focus of
the people who are already here who are
already following us and and enjoying
the stuff we have showing love and we
try to kind of focus on the stuff we
don't have so so that one really
resonated this is one of the things that
held me back the most because my biggest
fear is disappointing people my biggest
fear is that I'm going to I'm going to
get on stage or I'm going to come to an
interview and I'm going to let you down
and I'm not going to have an answer and
I'm not going to know what to say and I
don't want to waste your time I don't
want to waste the audience's time and
that used to hold me back a lot from
keeping the momentum going I might start
one thing and then like there's an
opportunity and and then say no or
cancel or or back out or like hope they
would cancel on me because my I would be
afraid that I would disappoint people so
the thing that always saved me that I
still use today is focus on who you are
serving you know like focus on who you
are serving instead of who you aren't we
in in the comparison game of starting a
YouTube channel or starting an Instagram
account or getting on Tik Tok it's
always easy to look at well but look at
look at whoever you know look at the
number one look at what Joe Rogan's
doing or look at what Evan carmichel is
doing or look at what whoever else is
doing and the game of who you're not
never ends there's always somebody who's
better than you at something right like
the only thing that you're best in the
world that is being Teemo right the only
thing I'm best in world is being EV kak
and there's always people who are better
than me at all these other skill sets
that I want to learn and get better at
and that's great because we never want
to stop learning you never want to have
it all figured out we want to be able to
climb forever but if you're only living
in the world of I'm not enough and like
who you're comparing yourself to I think
people that's what will often lead to
burnout that's what lead to people
quitting that's what lead to people
killing their momentum as opposed to
saying I am helping people right like
focus on who you are serving instead of
who you're not so in my first videos my
first video on
YouTube had three comments on it in a
year and one was my mom and one was my
sister and then one was some random guy
you know I was like so in a year of my
first video going up when people are
like I didn't get any comment man my
first video for a year only had one
comment by some random guy who I didn't
know and I saw that and like hey some
somebody commented on my video this is
great and so if you can focus on people
you know that they post something
Instagram and they have 40 views on a
video and he say I'm such a failure only
40 people saw this video well imagine if
you were going to go speak at a library
or or a school event or something like
40 people showed up wouldn't you be
excited wouldn't you be nervous wouldn't
you be like oh my God there's 40 people
here coming to see me but because it's
it's online we feel like we're just a
failure cuz somebody else posted one and
they got 40,000 and you're sitting here
with 40 and so I always just focused on
who I was serving those 40 people like
40 people watch this video and for maybe
for one of those people that this was a
life-changing video that for one person
the thing that I said was the piece of
advice that they needed to move the
needle forward in their life and that
always gave me
more fulfillment more happiness more
positivity knowing that I am helping
some people and that I can continue to
help more and when you start doing the
work to help and focus on those 40 they
take you to the 40,000 like if you do a
great job nurturing your community then
they take you to their friends and their
friends and their friends and that's how
you build up and grow so yeah I think um
the comparison game can often uh hold us
back there's some Advanced strategies
around that that can work but when you
focus on who you are serving instead of
who you're not I think it leads to a lot
more happiness which leads to a lot more
momentum as well was the serving with
the purpose to serve was also a kind of
like something serving yourself too was
that with were you attached to that
serving yeah I mean the ultimate form of
happiness is serving yeah I know if you
want fulfillment that it doesn't exist
unless I don't think it exists unless
you are serving other people like I
think as humans we want to wake up and
feel like today is going to matter
everybody wants to wake up and feel like
today is going to matter and mean
something to somebody else and some of
us you know you and I we want to impact
the world we want to have a big you know
ripple effect that that our positivity
you know reaches everybody uh and other
people you know my wife they just want
to serve the closest people in our
family you know like the 25 closest
people to us but in either case we all
want to wake up and feel like today is
going to matter and mean something to
somebody else if you woke up every day
and feel like it didn't matter if you
woke up today and felt like nobody cares
if I show up I'm not doing anything
meaningful my boss doesn't care about me
like it's just a waste of time like
that's the path to depression and
anxiety and stress and suicide and all
you know of problems that we have
because people don't feel like most
people wake up and drive to a job that
they hate they don't feel like what
they're doing matters where on the flip
side if you woke up and felt like today
was going to matter and mean something
then you're much more likely to show up
with energy and hope and optimism and so
I'm trying to do that for me every time
I go and help somebody I feel better
right so like this is part of like we
are we are interconnected as humans
where we want to feel like we're going
to do something that's going to mean
something to somebody else for people
who don't know what their direction is
where they want to go you said try
different things until you find
something that works for you like can
you elaborate on that or yeah at the
beginning it's it's a messy process
because you you grow up in a circle and
it's getting easier with YouTube and
internet Etc but uh if you grew up I
think of me growing up who did I know
it's my parents my family my school
you're kind of restricted by your
environment now at least we have YouTube
videos and you can learn whatever you
want to learn there's people out
there when you're struggling to figure
out what your career should be or what
your next move should be I think you'll
have moments in life where you have
absolute Clarity you know like maybe
you're in a moment now of absolute
Clarity I want to get my podcast
actually like kicking ass yeah right so
that's where like blinders on and go
kick ass on your podcast right you don't
need more you don't need to get into
nfts and like some Ai and crazy stuff
like go kickass in your podcast when you
have Clarity and there's other moments
in life and it's not just a per like
you'll have moments in life where you
don't know what to do next you sell your
podcast it blows up you sell it and
you're done it's like oh wow what do I
do and that's where you expand open to
say okay I need to try a bunch of stuff
to see what connects with me so should
everybody be an entrepreneur no but
should everybody try yeah cuz how do you
know you know should everybody love
sushi no but should everybody try yeah
cuz how do you know what your favorite
food is if you only eat pizza and hot
dogs all day how you started to create
your YouTube channel because me myself
along with many other YouTubers out
there are people who want to build their
YouTube following H how what do we do
how do how do we start to build and grow
our YouTube channel one is you just
start I think people are in their head
too much I think
people they're trying to be perfect
you're you're some big impossible plan
up in your head and then as you don't do
anything so you need to start you need
phone film your phone out turn it
sideways and start the film and post
your first video right what Marlo it's
suck first video is going to be
terrible thing ever in your life like
you got up on a bicycle and you fell off
you know you didn't just get up and ride
so don't expect to get on YouTube and be
great on camera you know you you could
have great like even you you've got
great speaking skills and you're great
with people and you love interviewing
you love talking it's still a learning
process to get great in front of the
camera some people can short shortcut
that path but it's still a path and so
just start get out of your way stop
being perfect expect it to suck and just
start two I would say you need to be
consistent so it doesn't matter where
you start where you start is not going
to be where you finish but you have to
move and you got to move consistently
and so there was a great quote I think
it was Will Smith but was talking about
how I'm not responsible for where I
started you know I was born where I was
born I can't change that but I'm
responsible for where I finish I get to
control where I go in life no matter
where I started and so people blame
their start and then they don't move but
it's like it's on you doesn't matter
where you came from you you can go
anywhere uh and so consistency you got
to practice you got to get better you
got to make daily content if you want to
get good at something if you want to if
you want to be Oprah Winfree level
Talent at something you have to do it
daily you know if you if you are making
a video a week you're just never going
to get world class at that thing just
like anything else if you if you did
anything else once a week you would
never become world class at that thing
might get decently good if you want to
be a chef and you're only practicing
cooking once a week you're never going
to be the oer Winfrey of cook of of that
right you're never going to do it so you
need to practice more so one just start
start with what you have start
immediately today like happy New Year
let's start right now today we're going
we're not waiting and then every day you
need to practice you need to practice
practice and you will slowly get better
how do you feel
about this kind of like world that is
going speeding so quickly with
information how do you find that Focus
to be like okay I have my faith but it's
overwhelming like what how do you find
that kind of place so first step like
the first step for me is
flipping it to get excited so when
something new comes out it's like okay
I'm excited to I'm excited to go learn
that thing AI comes out cool let's go
let's go learn about AI it's like
expecting to suck at it I don't know
anything about AI I don't know how to
program AI I didn't know how to do
anything inside of AI and okay let's go
learn we're we're filming this video on
the on the the day after Instagram or
Facebook just launches threads right
right so threads just come out it's a
Twitter competition and most people are
like oh my gosh threads
another social media thing why do we
need another place to go and doom scroll
on and great like I'm let me learn about
threads this is exciting I just try to
teach myself that when there's something
new let's go learn it it's exciting
because the rate of change is not going
to go slower right I agree so so this
becomes your key uh adaptation technique
is that anytime something new comes out
get excited go learn about it this is
how you can start to win and for anybody
who is earlier on in their
Journey whenever something new comes out
that actually becomes your secret hack
to go off and win so if you're trying to
get started and you're on Twitter it
might be hard for you to to win right
now because people have already been it
doesn't mean that you can't so you start
you start creating great but go to
threads it's brand new it's all the
people who are on Twitter like don't
want to go to threads because they built
up Their audience all the people in
Hollywood didn't want to go to
YouTube right like where's Brad Pitt's
YouTube channel he should be crushing
right now because he doesn't want to
start over right this is the problems
like people don't want to start over and
I don't know anything about Brad Pit no
shaded Brad uh but like some people make
the jump like Will Smith make the jump
and like starts blowing up on YouTube
but a lot of people don't a lot of
people stick to one platform and then
they they slowly become irrelevant and
so when something new comes up this is
your chance to go off and win like you
might not beat Joe Rogan at podcasting
but you can beat him on threads or you
can get close to him on threads and a
lot of the people who are are winning in
that first platform just don't want to
go and start over on the second one and
so this is your chance to get ahead and
so whether it's AI whether it's threads
whether it's an update to the YouTube
algorithm whether it's whatever the
thing is there's more
coming and there's and there's more
coming too so training yourself to be
the person who gets excited for new
Chang
because that's your chance to go and win
have a bigger impact make more money
like whatever actually drives you spread
more faith right whatever actually is
driving you this is your opportunity to
go off and do it and so for me that's
always been the default where like okay
why I don't it's always been a default I
think I've trained myself um to get more
excited about the new things that are
coming up uh and I just go in with the
student mind I expect to suck you know
like I don't somebody asked me about
threads today like hey what's your
thread strategies like I don't know I'm
two days in like I'm trying to figure it
out I don't even know what this is yet
I'm I'm maybe not the smartest person
but I'm I'm trying to understand it as
we go or when some new AI tool drops
okay let's understand what the heck this
thing even does and learning how to use
it so but it's just getting excited
about it and putting in a little bit of
effort to learn how to do it because so
many people they just get stuck on I
don't know how and it's new and scary
and so I don't do anything where really
you're actually not that far away from
for making momentum if you just put in a
little bit of effort are you of the
opinion then that if somebody has a job
but they have a feeling that they want
to be um an entrepreneur but they're
afraid of leaving their job are you of
the opinion that they should uh take a
take steps towards that and and if you
have a feeling for something try
it and just see and expect to suck but
at least you tried and you can see you
know do you want to go off and do it
again you had a feeling in the coffee
shop to come and ask me to connect if
you didn't follow the feeling that would
have been it like I would have my my
breakfast with Joe and then cow and off
right and I may never see you again you
had the feeling you followed it and it
may not always be good like maybe I'm
maybe I'm an ass maybe you're like dude
get out of my face you're weird stalking
me out of the bathroom right like maybe
like you don't know you don't know what
would happen but you have a feeling and
you have to follow the feeling cuz
otherwise you teach yourself that the
things that come to you are not great
because if every time you get an idea
and you don't follow through you're
teaching yourself that your idea suck
versus I have an idea I'm going to give
it a shot that's a great identity to
start to build it doesn't mean go
mortgage your home to go start a podcast
Studio like expect to suck and find the
smallest possible thing to just go and
get started so somebody who's working a
corporate job that hates their life okay
you're you're never going to win doing
work that you hate so so long long term
something has to change it doesn't mean
go like take a flamethrower to your
boss's office or something now like you
need the money you need the cool awesome
but longer term like we have to make a
change somewhere because you will never
be great doing work that you hate you're
never going to make the money never
going to be happy if you're doing work
you hate every day so how are you going
to get out of that hole that you're in
is it going to be somebody else telling
you what you should do with your life
that's going be like you have ideas for
what you it'd be cool if I could do this
okay go give it a shot
try it see if you liked it your first
podcast sucked cool and you get better
like you're better at eight episodes in
than I was at like 300 episodes in right
so but you try and so I think if you
have the feeling you want to teach
yourself that you come up with great
ideas and and they're worth at least
giving a shot to instead of just saying
you know there's sushi on the table I
don't like sushi without even giving a
shot cuz it sounds gross like if you had
to explain what Sushi is raw fish with
with fish eggs and seaweed with rice and
super spicy mustard that doesn't sound
appetizing right like why would anybody
eat that but then you eat it I like Su
with you guys but but you don't know
until you try so like you're judging
things before you're trying it and
especially when it's yourself you're
judging your ideas before you even try
it you're building uh the belief that
your ideas suck and that you suck and
then you stay stuck and so I I'm at
least you know encourage myself to try
to flip that that I have ideas that
saying yes to you okay let's go I'm not
going to judge it let's go do it what
skills does someone need to get into
this area of wanting to be an
entrepreneur what does it take I don't
think skills are the problem I think I
think you can learn anything if you have
a a commitment and passion to learn um
learn is your one word you know I think
I think learn the desire and willingness
to to go through crap and learn and get
better you could you could pick up
anything I I think I'm The Testament to
that in that I suck at the start of my
channel if you go back it's embarrassing
watching my first content it's really
really bad but I just kept learning and
said I can get better I'm gonna improve
I'm gonna keep working I'm gonna keep
getting better and and it worked and so
more than any specific skill I think
it's the mindset it's it's the desire to
learn and understand that I can do
better if you take that into any field
uh and match it with some self-a
awareness I think you're set like
there's so many different ways to win as
an entrepreneur there's so many
different ways yes you may not win the
same way that Gary ve win and so to have
the self awareness to know hey I'm I'm
Mara I'm great at talking to people I'm
going to do a talk show and then you can
model success and you can learn from
Oprah and you can learn from Larry King
and you can learn from all the great
talk show hosts and model some of their
Styles and every time you do that you
learn a little bit more to be a better
Mara and keep growing keep getting
better what do you think would gravitate
towards negativity a lot more when we
know it doesn't make us feel good
because it definitely drains you it
causes an impact I think it's biological
it's like if you it's like from the
history of US struggling right has to be
you I mean I don't know I don't not I'm
not a scientist and I don't have all the
answers there for sure but but like why
do we slow down and look at a car
accident even if it's on the other side
of the road totally get hit by looking
like if a fight breaks out on the street
it's like you're you know you want to
see what happens like we we are I don't
know where it comes from but like it it
it definitely is that people would
rather um consume negative things like
if I my first video was the top 10 rules
for Kanye West and was positive things
you can learn from Kanye if that was a
negative like top 10 stupidest things
Kanye has said it would it would do so
much better because I think I think if
I'm looking at it from the perspective
of what I do is like we we would rather
see people fail than than try to build
ourselves up right you know it's like oh
look at D she she's got her podcast and
she's been on movies and look at her
building her life and she she made it
out and now she's in LA and she's such a
big deal and yada y y and it's easier
for me to try to tear you down and want
to see you fail then for me to say huh
like maybe I can fix my life maybe I can
go to La too maybe I can start a podcast
maybe I can and and whatever the things
are that you know jealousy is really
just um ins inspiration that's been
mutated oh wow if I if I'm jealous of
you I'm actually inspired by you but I
don't know how to handle it so I take it
negative
totally so it's easier for me to tear
you
down than for me to try to work on
myself because don't have to do any work
that way right it's like yeah but then
yeah but she like totally sold her soul
to go do that and she and I'll make it I
make up some stuff that like doesn't
even make sense but it allows me to stay
where I'm at where I am right so that's
why a lot of a lot of even our friends
and family will often say not to go do
something because if you go off if you
go off to LA and you start becoming a
movie star and you start meeting people
what does it mean for
me you know like you you left me behind
and and now my life sucks cuz you're
showing what's possible and I'm living
in a fake reality I don't want to accept
that so it's not possible you must have
had to do something super
scammy terrible yeah like you killed
somebody or whatever you know you hide
someone in the closet and it's not
coming out yeah so I think that's like
it we don't doing work on yourself is
hard very learning new skills and making
new con ctions and going to a new
country or new city is hard it's really
hard and we don't want to do hard things
but your great life is on the other side
of of hard things and so when we see
somebody else who looks like us comes
from similar
background we want to find a reason why
that person should not be successful
we'd rather hate on them than Be
Inspired not everybody but a lot of
people yeah because we want it we prefer
to stay stuck than the grow the idea
with 2% difference is when we come up
with an idea like I'm going to launch a
YouTube channel I'm going to write my
own book I want to start a Instagram
book account like I want to do whatever
we all have these ideas of what we want
to do the first thing that we typically
do is start planning researching
planning who's done it before who can I
model and learn from all these ideas and
we create this giant list of plans and
what we're trying to do is plan to the
100% which is like that's what our final
destination is going to look like how do
I plan to get my goal and then we end up
waking up the next day
and you look at your plan you're like I
can't do that I thought what I'm not
that there's no way I can do that it's
not even like us telling our friends or
our spouses or it's it's us telling
ourselves that we can't do this and so
the problem is we used our energy our
our our mojo our our best like high
Vibes on planning instead of on doing
where again the biggest thing people are
missing just momentum planning doesn't
really count as momentum you have to to
go and do something and so instead of
worrying about planning to get to 100%
of our goal completed the 2% difference
is just start with the first 2% what's
what's the first 2% and we don't care
about getting to the end goal we just
care about getting started so that was
me in writing the book okay well I'm
going to write the book after this
Instagram live I'm going to start right
now it's easy for all the thoughts to
start to overwhelm yourself and I did
like I don't have time for this I this
is not on my plan I'm busy I have to
feel like I'm going to be a bad father a
bad husband a bad uh manager a bad CEO
like I don't have time for this right
and I share all those thoughts in the
book too so you can kind of peek behind
the window it wasn't like I really was
desperately wanting to do this going in
and then uh I just started writing so
like if anybody out here you want to
write your first book cool the the 2%
difference is write the first page and
it's okay if it sucks if you want to
start a YouTube channel the 2%
difference is record your first video
and it's going to suck awesome cool but
more important than planning how to make
a book or planning how to record a
YouTube video is to just start doing the
thing and you build momentum if you want
to start building a healthy habit you
want to you want to you want to start
working out right this is where we often
get overwhelmed like I want to work out
I want to look good next year I want to
I want to feel comfortable naked or
whatever we want to be able to do cool
so it starts off with this very simple
concept but then the doing becomes
really complicated because as you start
to plan and research a health Journey
right it's like oh well do I do weights
do I do cardio how much of each do I do
uh do I do classes do I hire a coach do
I how much am I supposed to wait am I
going to hurt myself am I going to
injure my back trying to do this thing
maybe I should take maybe I should go do
soccer or pick up a sport or pick up uh
basketball or oh but do I need a partner
to run with like can I overtrain and how
about nutrition like do I need to drink
am I drinking too much water not enough
water do I need to go carnivore or vegan
and all of a sudden it's like so many
this is what happens we get so
overwhelmed with all the potential
options which then leads us to try to
plan plan plan plan plan plan plan some
more but then you can't understand all
of the various options and then we end
up getting this is C I'm not doing I'm
I'm out I'm done and then you stop
before you even started right and so the
key is 2% difference if you want to
start a health Journey get down on the
floor and do five push-ups or 10 or two
right is it going to make you extra
strong no but it's the first step and
most people wait a decade to take the
first step and so that's what the 2%
difference is all about what advice do
you have for aspiring YouTubers that are
starting from ground
one uh expect a suck at the
beginning expect a suck like you might
look at Allan and say wow Allan looks so
great and he gets all these guests on
and he looks so professional and he asks
these great questions and he looks so
comfortable in front of the camera and
like I wish I could be Allen right but
but Allan wasn't Allen either at the
beginning you know Allan sucked at the
start go watch episode one I don't know
I haven't seen episode one but it's
probably not as clean and Polished and
there's mistakes and flubs and like
episode one is supposed to suck so just
expect to suck at the start don't don't
take that as you suck as a human like
that's the problem is we make something
it sucks we watch ourselves back on
camera it's like oh my gosh I was so bad
I can't believe it was that bad and then
we internalize that to feel like well
well we suck and I'm just not good at
this and it's not meant for me and never
do it no like you get on a bike and you
fall off this this is the nature of
learning any skill it's just a skill so
expect to suck at the beginning and then
create go make like make another video
and another video and another video it
took me 350 videos until I wasn't
completely embarrassed by my stuff like
I couldn't watch it back I would I would
press play a it's so bad 350 videos and
700 videos until I inspired myself where
I watched the video like you know what
what like I'm I might be getting good at
this thing huh 700 videos in and I think
most people can get there a lot faster
than it took me to get down that path um
and we just have these unrealistic
internal expectations for how good we
should be so expect to suck and then
just go create and keep making content I
think one of the biggest mistakes I made
early on when I when I had any money was
I just tried to invest it and put into
the stock market and M like I had 2,000
bucks like okay I'm going to put it in
the stock market and it's going to grow
I like oh it's like taking so long to
grow it's only 2,000 bucks where Jeremy
actually made a much smarter call like I
think at the beginning you invest in
your skills and you invest in your
network because that $2,500 investment
that Jeremy made now has a mid six
figure or high six figure business every
year because he came to that event but
if you just put it into the stock market
sure it would grow but I think at the
beginning and you need to invest in
yourself to get the skills that you need
to be able to then create the network
and create value for other people yeah
and and when entrepreneurs any
entrepreneur here watching you're
thinking about starting your business
the easiest way to start making money is
to provide a high value business or
service to people who have money to pay
you and so getting into YouTube
Consulting is great because there's not
a ton of people into it yeah right it
hasn't been around for 40 years if
you're going to get into tax accounting
that's a great business to be in too but
you have to have years of experience to
know what you're doing right I did um I
did an interview with Tom on his channel
like that guy's an expert he's a genius
he's a genius so if you're going to go
and compete with Tom it's going to take
you so many years to even catch up to a
base level of knowledge but in YouTube
Consulting it's easier because there is
nobody really who's been doing this for
40 years right or you're a chat GPT
consultant and you're helping use AI for
people in the C who is the expert on
that like there's nobody cuz it's still
so brand new so this is the area where
it's super high value for clients but
there aren't a lot of experts at it so
for you to spend 6 months becoming great
at it you could be now in the top 1% of
all people who know how to use that
thing and then start charging for your
services on top of it what is the
importance of video influencers watching
maybe thinking about focusing their
branding and their messaging yeah I
think if you're a human being you have a
core value there's something inside of
you that is the most important value in
the world something that you place
higher than money and when you figure
out what that is and then you bring that
not just to your business but to your
life the people you hang out with but in
the context of creating a YouTube
channel the content like how do you
stand out if you are another family
vlogger another gamer another
entrepreneur and there's tons of
competition how do you do it it's based
off of what is the single most important
core value that you want people to feel
cuz I want people to feel an emotion
when they watch my videos when they
watch these interviews I want you to
feel an emotion and not just get content
got it so your one word is believe right
it is what's the story behind that how
did you come over that uh it came from
my parents they always taught me that I
was in I was Evan custy carmichel I
could do anything that I wanted it's a
message I still pass on to my son and
they just made me feel like whatever I
wanted to do it was possible and to
believe in myself to do it and it's it's
come through my entire life my favorite
movie is Sea Biscuit it's about this
horse that is too small and a jockey
that's too big and a owner that had no
money they come together it's say
Underdog Story and so anything around
believe just I feel better about now
translate that to a YouTube world when I
had my channel I saw my channel but like
my first video that took off that did
well was this video took me a year to
get to 100,000 views on it and I was
like I was so happy 100,000 views for a
lot of you watching and maybe more than
what you have right now I was so pumped
I made a video around believe which was
my one word and we hit 100,000 views in
a month and that video now has over 2
million views and now believe oozes out
of everything that I create so I'm
trying to give you the content that you
can use to grow your business but I want
you to feel out of every piece of
content that you can go off and do
whatever your main Big Goal is I want
you to feel believe out of everything
that I create how do you come up with
your video ideas to keep your community
engaged that's a combination of what do
I want to make with what are people
asking for and I think that's at the
success of any any successful business
not just a YouTube channel not just a
podcast or show it's like what do you
love doing with where is their demand if
you take something that you just love
doing but nobody cares you have a
hobby great could be a really fulfilling
hobby but it's just a hobby and if you
take something that everybody wants but
you don't really care about you're never
going to win because you're you're doing
work that you hate and there's somebody
else out there who loves doing that
thing and so don't spend your time doing
work that you hate so it's in that
combination of like what do I love doing
with what do people actually want that
every business can become successful so
for me um we get a lot of feedback from
the audience people leave comments like
hey i' love to see a video on blank and
maybe I know how to do that and maybe I
really resonate with that or maybe I
don't and and then we don't um or just
starts with me saying I think this could
be a cool idea and then I try to make
that video and put it out there uh and
sometimes they take off and they do well
and we do a lot more and sometimes it
completely flops it's like okay cool
well nobody lik that move on to the next
idea I think the key though within all
of that is we're not so attached to this
thing having to work a lot of times
people when they're first launching
their YouTube channel their business
their podcast whatever we put so much
pressure on the on the launch being
perfect and then if it doesn't work out
we feel like a failure where for me it's
just okay we're going to try that and
we're going to try this we're going to
try that and and something's going to
work and if that that thing yesterday
didn't work cool I've got 18 more ideas
I'm going to try until I find a thing
that does work I think it's a really
hard road to become an entrepreneur how
did you find your Mentor cuz that's
that's really hard for a lot of people
yeah the trick is when you when you find
somebody who you like who you think
they're ahead of you and you think they
might have something to contribute like
just you have to find a way to get
closer to them so I'll give you two
stories the first with me and Steve uh I
met Steve through one of his clients so
one of his clients was in Toronto same
city as me and we met at a coffee shop
and he had this idea for the to pitch on
a YouTube video and uh he said that his
agent came up with this idea he's like
agent like what do you mean agent how do
you have an agent you're like a business
guy or like a YouTuber how do you have
an agent because I thought agents were
only for sports stars or musicians like
how do you it's like yeah I have an
agent he represents like thought leaders
like ah okay can I can I meet him and uh
so he introduced me to Steve I hopped on
the call Steve made me feel very
uncomfortable you know in all the in all
the right ways um and and that led to me
wanting to do more with him even though
I didn't fit the typical mold so it's
it's following the Curiosity right if I
never I met I met this guy in Toronto
his name was Shawn and if I never asked
Shawn about the agent I wouldn't have
had that conversation um fast forward a
couple years ago there was a guy Jeremy
who came to one of my events and he's
paid like 2500 bucks or something to
come to event he's 18 19 years old he is
working as a grocery store clerk okay
like hates his life doesn't want to work
grocery store doesn't know what he
really wants to do
likes my energy saw my YouTube videos
come to the event it's 3-day event at
the end of the event he messages me says
hey Evan I just want to how do I spend
more time with you I don't have any
skills yet but I'll I'll walk your dog
I'll I'll clean your car I'll mow your
lawn like I just want to spend more time
with you and I messaged him back said
that's super amazing Jeremy but I don't
like I don't need somebody to walk my
dog or clean my car but um but thank you
um a couple months later I was driving
on my tour and I'm driving through this
desert in Texas and I think of Jeremy
and I thought huh maybe I could teach
Jeremy YouTube like I wonder people keep
asking me about YouTube and they want me
to do work on their Channel and I don't
I don't want to do that as a business
but maybe I could teach Jeremy how to do
it and so we got Jeremy on the phone
that moment oh uh he he took a little
break from his grocery store you know
job and said Jeremy I want to teach you
YouTube we'll start a business together
and I'm away for the next two months on
the road so I need you to watch all of
these videos and learn everything you
can about YouTube and when I come back
if you've done that I'll help you build
a YouTube Consulting business wow um and
we did and now he's got uh a high sixf
fig YouTube business uh Consulting he he
made six figures in the first six months
or so of having his business um and
that's from being a grocery store clerk
right but if he didn't do that Outreach
to me I wouldn't have taking a shot on
him either it's just the the heart and
the energy and the care and he's just
I'll wash your car and I'll clean you
know hang out with your dog I just love
the energy and even though nothing came
up in the moment he was in the back of
my mind to say okay maybe I should do
something with jery and so it's it's
trying to be in a room where you get to
talk to them but then it's it's almost
uh uncomfortable like next ask and
showing your hunger and your commitment
level and then the key thing is when you
get that is you ask one question to the
mentor cuz successful people actually
love mentoring but they also hate
wasting time like time is the most
valuable asset and they love mentoring
but they hate wasting time and a lot of
mentees waste time yeah because they
don't do the work so the best thing you
can do if you want if you're trying to
get into a mentorship relationship you
ask one question like what's the one
question you've got to ask Robert Kaki
one question like what's the one
question that you want to ask him right
and then don't ask another question CU
that's what people will do they'll come
back and say oh what about this and what
about that it's like no no no like do
the work on the first question that he
gave you an answer for yeah and then go
home and actually do the work and if you
get a result then you can come back and
ask the second question hey I asked you
this I did this now my I've got five
Apartments man thank you from your
advice now I'm struggling with this he's
much more likely to give you a second
answer because of the work you did on
the first one yeah or if the advice
didn't work make sure that tried it a
hundred times right it wasn't just you
tried you made one phone call and it
didn't work and so the the advice sucked
right because if you tried it a 100
times and he showed the effort then he's
willing to answer a second question Evan
you have a brand new book called
momentum I love the word momentum I
think it's the hardest thing to get and
the easiest thing to lose why the book
momentum and why now
brother uh I actually wasn't planning on
writing the book at all buil to serve
was my book I was like it's still the
book and then I did a a session with my
now business partner uh Kira and we did
an IG live together and she kind of
pulled it out of me and uh this idea
just came out like momentum that's
that's the book I often tell people the
only thing they're missing is momentum
like you have the heart and you have the
idea and you have the the willingness to
serve and like you're doing it for the
right reasons and you deserve to make
money what's missing just momentum like
you're overthinking you're over you're
over you're over planning you're just
over over and you're not doing enough
like momentum uh and so she challenged
me to write the book in8 weeks weeks my
first book took me a year to write and
then she said well when are you g to
start and the book's called momentum
right it's like when of course I have to
start now like I'm gonna start next week
I'm gonna start in a month like no I
have to eat my own dog food and so I
wrote it uh I wrote it like got off the
call with her 3 pm Eastern and just
started writing and I wrote it in five
days it's like this book was written in
five days and we ended up having it
published in eight weeks and so when
you're you're to Dave's point of like
when you're in the right frequency and
around the right people and hitting the
right vibration like you can create
Magic and if you're not it's because
you're in the wrong frequency around the
wrong people and you have the wrong
thinking in your head too what system or
process do you have are are used for
your filming and editing is there
particular
methodology um I think that's evolved
over the years at the beginning I
probably spent way too much time trying
to figure all the stuff out you know my
first video took me a full day to record
because I was trying to it was one video
it's like six minutes it took a whole
day to record cuz I was trying to get it
perfect and the camera and the lighting
and my friend came in who's a
professional videographer and he filmed
me and I had to memorize my script and
uh over the years has gotten a lot more
streamlined and faster and I've cared
less about it being perfect and more
about me just showing up and trying to
connect more to the heart and less to
the head if we had done this interview
even three years ago I would have said
okay I need to know what are Allan's
questions going to be I want to know
what his questions are uh because I
wanted to have an answer because I would
be afraid of I don't want want to
disappoint your audience I don't want
you to ask me some question I'm like oh
my gosh I don't know but what would end
up happening is I give a really prepared
rehearsed answer which then doesn't
actually bring the most value to your
community and so instead like I don't
want to know the questions I don't want
to know you know what you're going to
ask me let's just go with it and hope
that um I have enough inside me to be
able to share and
so I wish I had done that sooner you
know if you look back I probably
wouldn't have made changes but like if I
could talk to Evan who starting this
Channel at the beginning it's like don't
be so stressed out about saying the
perfect words and having the perfect
lighting and gear and editing process
just go make create and the more you can
connect in your heart instead of your
head and what you think is perfect the
better results you'll actually have
where do we learn to manage people you
don't learn that in school right we
don't learn how to manage people we're
at Tau usually the opposite in school
which Robert loves talking about it's
like it's cheating it's cheating to look
at somebody else's test to work together
right you got to do it all by yourself
but like that's the opposite in business
you have to do it as a team so where do
we learn the ability to manage and
delegate we don't right I think a lot of
people even if you think about school
projects we're usually the ones like
hard carrying the school projects or
we're taught to be like the smartest
person in the room right like you always
want to compete against the person next
to you or Robert teaches us like you
don't want to be the smartest person in
the room you want your team to be the
smartest people in the room it's
completely counter to what we learn in
in the school system so so great you
know if you've never LED somebody before
you're probably not going to be a great
boss it doesn't mean you're going to be
a terrible boss you're going to chew
them out and they're going to hate you
but you need to learn how to actually
manage people and so it's easier to
manage somebody for an hour a day
part-time while you're still running
your company than to have a full-time
person who you now committed to it's
very rare that the first employee at any
company is still there look at employee
number one and 10 years later like that
person's gone not because the person
sucked it's because you sucked as a
leader yeah like you don't know how to
hire you don't know how to delegate you
don't know how to manage you don't know
how to train we think that we get
somebody in and then oh this person's
just going to take off all my problem
you got to you got to train them you got
to Mentor them you got to help and so
it's easier to get started like that's a
skill that you will that will serve you
for the rest of your life no matter what
you end up doing I'm a big believer that
the ideas that come to you when you're
feeling bold excited powerful inspired
like those are the right ones for you
and then we spend most of our time
talking ourselves down from like why we
can't do the things so if you if you're
watching a Craig video or a Dave video
you're hanging out and you get inspired
like that idea that's the that's the
that's your best version talking to you
and you owe it to you to go do something
and take the first step like you get
inspired to go start your own IG live or
your own YouTube channel awesome like
just make a video people get caught up
like what camera and what microphone and
what am I gonna talk about and then it's
like you're it's over it's over like
just press record and make your first
video that's the first step and that's
like people people take a decade to get
to the first step that's the problem so
the ideas that come to when you're
feeling bold those are the right ones
for you what are some of your best tips
and practices for entrepreneurs staying
charged staying focused and growing
really in their leadership and as
entrepreneurs so first off I think you
have to be do something that you
absolutely love if you look at any of
the successful entrepreneurs you look up
to or in any field athletes singers
musicians artist you have to love the
work of what you're doing and not just
try to be YouTube famous if you're
watching this trying to be YouTube
famous it's not going to get you
anywhere you have to love the actual
process of making videos and being able
to influence people yeah editing wise
that you landed that plane yeah love it
okay so what else the other important
thing really is that you need to have a
morning routine that sets you up for
Success so we talked about like what's
one thing that you can't miss you need
to have that can't miss stuff in your
morning routine to get you charged to
energized because too often what happens
is people get motivated you watch one of
these videos you're not subscri
subscribed yet you haven't hit the Bell
so you only to one video you get all
pumped and then next day you wake up and
like it's gone yeah and we all we all
have that we don't say we do but we have
it you wake up nobody wakes up every day
like Mega passion to go and so you need
to whatever that is that gets you
excited if it's if it's watching this
guy every day then watch him every day
like you need to put that into your
morning routine so you start your day
feeling energized and bold and on fire
to go do amazing things as opposed to
shrinking down and then by accident you
come across something that gets you
pumped up the why is your purpose and
your purpose comes from your pain you
don't have to go sit on a mountain top
for 20 years to meditate on what your
purpose is your purpose is to help
people who currently are who you used to
be so whatever you came through you
struggled you suffered to get here and
not not physical pain like you broke
your arm or something like emotional
pain when did you feel just worthless as
a human being go back to that moment and
understand that there are millions of
people right now who current are that
millions of people who currently are in
my case 19-year-old Evan in your case
whatever you know your old Tina maybe
was 19-year-old Tina 2 trying to figure
out where to go in life there's millions
of people who currently are right there
like right now they're facing the same
problems and you represent hope to them
like you made it out you you forged your
own path you're you're you're an
impossibility like 19-year-old Tina
would look at this Tina and say that
you're not going to do that you're not
going to be having this show you're not
going to be on NBC you're not going to
have a book you're not going to do this
stuff but and yet you did it so you're
an
impossibility so going back and helping
19-year-old Tina you'll open up her eyes
and make you realize that I don't have
to end up here I can end up in a
different spot if I want to and then
just recognizing that there are millions
of 19y old tinas around the world that
you could help and will love to help and
so we are we are hardwired to serve
serving hits the same part of your brain
as having food and having sex like it's
literally hardwired into to you as a
human but who do you serve not not
everybody's equal you could you could
hold the door for somebody you know your
your condo or at a mall or something
it'll make you feel good for the moment
but it's not the same as helping
somebody who currently is who you used
to be um and again that will never get
old I do the interview and I was so
nervous going into it that I'm wearing
these you know thick kind of hoodie that
I was sweating all through like the Tony
interview like oh my God more in the
leadup but after I'm so hot like I can't
breathe I mean yes we did it but I'm I'm
sweating buckets and so I take off my
shirt to cool off but I have five
minutes until my next show with somebody
else where I'm being interviewed and so
I get on and I forget to put my hoodie
back on so I'm in my undershirt and this
is what I want to train you and other
people the immediate voice in my head is
oh I need to oh my God look at myself
like we went we started recording my
camera comes on like oh my God
I didn't realize but then right away
it's like no I'm going to do this as
opposed to the guy would have been fine
to say hey oh my God I'm sorry can I
just put my hoodie on I'm sure he's
gonna say yes right but I want to lean
into that discomfort and so he did the
whole interview in my undershirt just
because nice you
know just because now this guy I mean
hopefully this guy gets a unique
interview it's different um than
everybody else and so that that like
it's constantly trying to lean
into those moments whether it's on
camera or not that I'm afraid to do this
what am I afraid of I'm afraid of being
judged right like I'm in I could be in
my undershirt all day but I don't want
to be on the in my undershirt in front
of other people right and so because of
that fear I don't want that fear to own
me so I have to step into it and now I
could do it again if I needed to right
it's not an expression of me right like
I don't want to walk around all day in
my undershirt it's an undershirt for a
reason but I could do it if I wanted to
and I don't want that fear to control me
and I think a lot of people don't do
things because of the fear they don't
post to Instagram because of how it
might be judged they don't post a
YouTube because of how people might look
at them they don't ask for that
interview because they might get a no
right yeah so every time I feel that
fear or potential embarrassment then I
want to I want to step in and do it and
worst case it becomes a great story I
think motivation is like shortterm so
there's got to be like a long-term
solution I think the key to that is like
momentum because like once you start
getting wins and like you you start
feeling like that high from winning like
it just kind of it gets addicting and
it's obviously all starts with small
winds like just waking up when you tell
yourself you're gonna wake up it gets it
gets addictive because you start to
change your identity for
yourself you start to see yourself as
somebody who's successful who's having
success that's the addictive part it's
like I'm I'm a successful person like I
am starting to get results I feel great
about myself that I'm getting these
results and so that's why hitting the
sze button is the opposite you're
telling yourself that you
suck telling yourself I don't hit my
goals so you have to be very careful
about the goals you set for yourself and
to make sure you follow through and I
love momentum and I think you should if
you did something every day that made
yourself feel proud like I'm proud of
myself today yeah like you guys you're
proud of yourself for doing whatever and
I can't judge what you feel proud of or
not but if you're proud of yourself
every day for doing something whether
you get a result or not just the fact
that you try to do something and you're
proud of that that builds your self
resect that creates momentum that
changes your life what questions do you
tend to ask yourself every day or if
there's just one question what do you
ask
yourself um I think the most important
one is what's my intention for the day
so the first thing that I do is I wake
up and ask what's what's my intention
for today what is today you know so so
we're recording this on a Thursday
Thursday is my public facing day that's
when I I put my extrovert hat on and I'm
doing interviews and group meetings and
we had our Movie Makers this morning and
then I had a podcast now I'm on your
show then I'm gonna have to do like it's
just all day long it's going to be
interviews and podcasts and shows
and yesterday was my project day and I
just have the whole day open do whatever
I want and Tuesday was my YouTube day
and tomorrow's my CEO day and when I'm
in it I'm not thinking about what's next
like today all I care about is your show
and what I'm doing now and then my next
interview I'm going to think about their
show I what am I doing tomorrow I don't
know I mean I know it's CEO day but I
don't even know what I'm supposed to be
doing tomorrow until I get to tomorrow
so I use the morning as a reset to
say oh what am I what am I doing today
oh today's Thursday okay Thursday I I
wake up like I have no idea what I'm
doing you know it's like I wake up like
what day is today what am I supposed to
be working on it's not like I wake up
and say I'm ready it's Thursday let's go
fam come on right like I nobody wakes up
like that and so I wake up and I'm uh
you know I don't know what I'm doing and
I look at the calendar and and I look at
what I'm doing for the day so who Am I
who am I having on oh I'm gonna be on
financial developer oh yeah I love that
guy he was on my YouTube live stream uh
oh today's movement makers day awesome
oh and I'm doing this stuff coming up
great and I just want to get myself
ready what's my intention for today I
want to try to bring the best for all
the people that I'm trying to show up
for my intention is to try to be my best
for you here today for every other you
know interview I'm doing for Movie
Makers this morning it's my intention uh
maybe I don't hit it you know may maybe
maybe you walk away and say Evan man
that sucked that was the worst interview
I've ever seen you do awesome it's like
it was still my intention to show up
right because when you're thinking about
something else if I'm here talking to
you and I'm thinking about what I'm
doing this weekend I'm not yeah I'm not
here for you I'm not
creating I think it's disingenuous to
the int
my for the day and I'll look at my
calendar and think your calendar should
be a reflection of your goals okay right
like if you want to accomplish your
goals yeah there's habits that have to
happen yeah otherwise it's just an idea
if you don't do anything right if you
just I have all these ideas of who I
want to interview if you're never
reaching out it's never going to happen
so in your calendar has to
be actions that will help you accomplish
your goals why is there so much
negativity in the system well it's
because there's a lot of pain in the
system uh when you've been in pain did
you always show up as your best self did
you show up and do things that you were
super proud of when you were hurting in
a lot of pain right probably not right
like you all you come out and you do a
lot of negative things sometimes and so
just understanding that can can take a
lot of the sting out of people's words
this isn't a bad person this isn't a
toxic person they're just in a lot of
pain and we expect people who are in
pain to to lash out and do bad things um
anyway once you figure out what that who
is that serves you for life so if yours
is believe then now you know the kinds
of people who you need on your team if
you're going to hire a video editor it's
great if they have all the skill sets of
how to cut videos together but they
better love belief they better they
better be a person who likes belief it
doesn't necessarily have to be their who
but it's got to be pretty close so now
you know the kinds of people that you
want to attract into your life you know
the message that you want to put out
there to the world it becomes the lens
through which you see the world and
anytime that you're not happy it's
because there's a lack of belief
somewhere lack of belief in yourself
lack of belief in the relationships
around you lack of belief in the team
members that you've got um lack of
belief in the projects that you've got
going on that leads to unhappiness and
so it's also a quick fix you we just
need to have more belief in the system
for us to be happy and that's for
anybody figure out you're who it gives
you that road map for happiness for the
rest of your life and it doesn't get old
like that Tina will be 120 years old
still believing in other people
it's not going to be like oh this year
I'm GNA switch it to something else like
no that's who you are how do you
personally set goals and then what
happens if you don't hit a goal because
like it does happen sometimes and like
obviously what matters is what you do
about it so so here's the thing so I
don't most of my goals are habits
they're not like I want to make x amount
of money by the end of the year it's the
habits right it's not I want to be able
to lift x amount it's I want to I want
to be spending half an hour in the gym
every day or I want to make sure I'm
waking up at this time every day it's
the habits you can check off and say I
did
that so I think that's where most people
will mess up on their goals it's it's
the daily habits you are what you
consistently do it's not about achieving
that outcome it's about being the person
who can achieve that outcome and that's
by setting daily and weekly consistent
habits for yourself if you don't hit it
for some
reason then the big question is are you
proud of the reason
why so I had a guy I'm doing this tour
right now I'm driving in the car between
Sacramento and and Salt Lake City
somewhere in Nevada right now desert
this wild um I had a guy in my Columbus
stop and he said hey Evan I I had a goal
that I wanna I want to do six days a
week cold showers okay one day off
Saturday off six days a week cold
showers it was Friday night my workshop
he said my heat's been out all day I've
been at my girlfriend's house all day
her heat was off and so I've been
freezing all day long and so I I didn't
do my cold shower like I said I would
should I do my cold
shower I said well are you proud of the
reason why you didn't do
it he said no okay then you have to go
take a cold shower and then tomorrow you
have to take another cold shower even
though it's your day off just to show
yourself what you're capable
of and so when you don't do something
it's are you proud of the reason why not
right so like I'm on this tour right now
90 days 23
cities I'm I'm two-thirds of the way
through as we're
talking I've committed to going to the
cities I've sold tickets in these
different cities you know if my mom went
to the
hospital tomorrow for something I would
cancel my tour and go home and be with
my mom I didn't follow through my goals
I didn't do what I said I was going to
do I'm disappointing a whole bunch of
people who bought tickets and I do my
best to make it up to them but I'm not
going to make everybody happy like some
people will be pissed at me yeah but am
I proud of the reason why I didn't do my
goal hell yeah so I'm okay with it right
so when you set a goal you have to
follow through and if you don't then
then are you proud or the reason why not
and if you're not then you have to come
back twice as strong the next day just
to show yourself how do you uh make your
team better like how do you like to go
ahead and try and make improve your team
day today think it's caring about them
as people wanting them to win as humans
more than you want them to win with
you I want the people on my team to win
as people more than I want them to win
with
me now quite often it's a similar path
it's like hey you want to do this your
best path is to stay with me and I'll
help you get there but it may mean that
they have to leave and go do something
else right like Zan if you watch our our
live stream xan is my co-host yeah um I
want xan to win M more than I want him
to win with me and that may mean he has
to jump off at some point and not be my
co-host on this stream if I ever felt
like me being with Zay on the stream
wasn't in his best interest I would kick
him out I would kick him out like Dan I
love
you you can't be here anymore you have
to go do that thing I'm not gonna let
you stay here you have to go off and do
that thing it's it's even though he's
bringing so much value to me it's
actually holding him back if I felt I I
don't feel that way I think it's great
for him but if I did I push him away
towards the thing that he should be
doing and when you when you do that most
people only think what can this person
do for me when you think what does this
person need and how can I help them
often again there's parallel
paths but at some point some people may
have to divert and go do something else
maybe somebody's with you for life maybe
somebody's with you for 10 years maybe
somebody's with you for 10 months or 10
hours and and they have to go off and do
their thing but while we're together I'm
I just want you to win as a human and
when people feel that you get their not
just their brain but you get their heart
and their soul I don't think people grow
up with a healthy perspective on money
some people like you alluded to think
money is everything and and the next
person coming in that's my next purse
and that's my next she's my next suit or
she's my next car or whatever uh and
money is is everything and there's other
people though which I find a lot more in
my community who think money is the root
of all evil right it's actually the love
of money is the root of all evil but it
gets shorten to money is the root of all
evil and so you're afraid to make money
and you think money is bad and money is
you shouldn't make money you have to
make money I think money needs to be in
especially if you want to be an
entrepreneur money has to be in your top
five list of priorities it just can't be
number
one but it's not number 1,000 either
like you have to learn how to monetize
and make money because if you want to
serve if you're stuck in some job that
you hate and you're only serving for
free on the weekend and evenings you're
limited to how much you can help but if
you can turn this into a full-time
business and then hire people on your
team and now you've got 10 20 100 people
working for you all aligned to this
mission that you're on to save people
right imagine the impact you can have
because you learned how to make money it
just can't be number one so the last
section of the book talks about how to
turn that those ideas you got that
passion you got the big heart into
something that can actually serve the
world but also make you money do you
believe we're born to do something or do
we just find something along the way I
think everybody has what I call Michael
Jordan level Talent at
something most people never find
it uh I believe even the the greatest
basketball player of all time isn't
Michael Jordan it's somebody you've
never heard of it's a manager at
Starbucks cuz he never picked up a
basketball and so he could have been the
greatest of all time and instead he's a
manager at Starbucks and he's okay with
his life instead of being great at
something
and so I don't know you know I don't I
don't know about the words destined or
anything like that but I I believe
everybody has that kind of talent you
have genius level Talent at something
and you've got to go and figure out what
that is and it's it's your
responsibility not just to yourself but
to your community to your family to the
people around you to the world to then
share it share that gift and so part of
the path to finding it is just trying
things you know maybe not everybody
should be an entrepreneur but everybody
should try it you should try it and see
like did I like that did I was that fun
was that enjoyable do I want to keep
doing that and if it's not great then go
do something else I think too many
people don't try enough things we get
locked into a career path way too soon
and then you don't know how to get off
of it and then the further on you get
the more responsibilities you have the
more difficult it is to jump off and do
your own thing and so I think it's
everybody's responsibility first of
themselves to have a happy life to
figure out what they have Michael Jordan
level Talent at taking risk while you're
young
cuz a lot of people don't like
understand that like I mean people that
are listening that are like in
christianized spot like we're young and
like we don't have a lot to worry about
like now is the time to take that risk
like if you ever had the thought of
being an entrepreneur I feel like now is
the time to like try it out because jobs
are going to be available like later
down the road yeah you know I think now
is now is always the right
answer like it's easier when you're when
you're young but I'm I'm 38 now now 38
39 in May great like if I was in a job
that I hated as a 38 39 year old and I
hated my
life now is the time what I'm gonna wait
another 30 years of working for some
company that I hate you know like now
was always the right time that was
people wait for the perfect time it
never comes and then and then you end up
in a retirement home regretting your
entire life so now is always the time if
you could get
anyone who is struggling not making
money in their business and they're
doing what they love and they're putting
the hard workor and effort in what would
your one piece of advice
be um so on the business side I would
say you have to learn how to figure out
how to bring value to people so doing
what you love is not enough but chasing
strategy alone isn't enough either so a
successful business comes from mixing
what you love doing with what brings
value to other people if you just love
something but it doesn't bring bring
value you have a hobby and that could be
a great Hobby and fulfilling but it's
not going to become a business and if
you're just chasing opportunity what's
the hot business for this year you're
never going to ultimately win longterm
because your heart's not connected to it
so and you're going up against people
who love the thing and so it's in that
combination of the thing you love doing
that brings value to the people that you
have a successful business but I know
you only ask for one but I i' layer on
top of it just believe in what you're
doing like come back to the intent is is
my intent to serve is my intent to help
my even just helping three people I know
as entrepreneurs we want more more more
more more it's like we want to serve the
world we got to change Global
Consciousness right I mean this is where
we want to go but but did you help one
person this week you know did one person
benefit and so imagine if you stopped
you know if you stopped then those
people won't get the message and if you
look back if you if you I try to
position sometimes to regret I imagine
myself being 120 looking back at this
moment it's like if I quit now will I
regret it and if so then just keep going
and if you can continue to focus on who
you are serving it's more the the mental
approach because when you feel like
you're doing something that matters and
you feel like you matter you just show
up with a lot more love and energy and
care than otherwise and so if your
intent is to serve and to help just keep
going because the world needs people
like you so I think a lot of people try
to forget about the past pain I think
especially entrepreneurs we're so you
know optimistic we want to make the
world better we're trying to live in a
positive Place uh that I had actually a
hard time remembering some of the super
painful moments and I don't like going
there but instead of trying to forget
and move past it if you can go live
there again just as a reminder of what
it felt like so that you can then help
other people living there and dwelling
on mistakes and and the hurt doesn't
help anything right but if it allows you
to connect with the people who are
currently going through that situation
and I think that becomes your path like
for the reason why I came up with
purpose from your pain is it's one of
the most common questions I get is
what's my purpose how do I find my
people are walking around with no
purpose they don't know what it is and I
think everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something I think you can be a
genius at something and I know that like
Unleash Your greatness is what you're
all about it's great uh but people don't
know how to find it and I think it
starts with that it starts with
understanding some of the pain and
Trauma that you've been through whatever
that was for you and then then create
something amazing you know every great
organization every great entrepreneur
who started out of a pain that they had
and then they wanted to go off and solve
it and so diving back into your past to
think about what were some really
painful moments and then how can you
turn that as a kick forward not a kick
down not that you know you suck but
you're gonna now help others and and
make it better um and sharing the story
I think it's how entrepreneurs win I
think I think too often we're afraid to
share a lot of people be afraid to share
your story like you're coming out of
Tony Robins organization you're on top
of the world you're improving people's
lives and and you're sitting you know in
your parents' basement and it's five
years like that that story is what makes
people human it's what connects people
to each other and I think so many people
are trying to start a business uh try to
be so corporate and so professional and
it's not that you can't be professional
but the thing that's going to make
somebody want to work with you and
connect with you in your mission is your
story I need to know why this is so
important to you why is this pain so
important and if you're telling some you
know fluffy story it's not going to work
but if it's true and real to you then
that's what's really going to draw
people in I love learning different
things from different people I'm in my
home office and you can see pictures for
those listeners I guess there's pictures
behind me on the my parents are in the
middle that's in the middle is me when
I'm like eight or nine and my above me
believe my one word my most important
core value comes from them um they
taught me how to be a human they didn't
teach me about business that's right so
okay great I've got Steve Jobs on the W
here next to me he I like learning how
to be a Visionary like Steve Jobs yes
but I don't want to be a father like
Steve Jobs was that's right I want to be
a father like my father was that's right
and so I love learning different things
from different people I think anybody
who's had success you can learn from
them and I honestly think some of your
greatest learnings will come from people
who you don't like had success they can
teach you when you can learn to learn
from someone who you don't like is when
I think you actually start learning wow
and so my favorite comment of all time
on my channel i profiled a a a black
entrepreneur and I had a guy leave a
comment and say hey growing up my
parents told me that black people were
the n-word yeah and today I just learned
from a black man yeah absolutely right
took five minutes to to watch a video
and and be open like hey put your put
your prejudices aside for five minutes
that's right and just see if there's
something here that you might learn if
you were looking at me and saying Andrea
you got to Define your Niche you got to
choose one or the other or is there a
way to emerge two things into one in
your
opinion so if you're looking at your
audience and picking your Niche what I
what I love to do is build around a core
value so if you do if you're looking at
health and
spirituality those are not mutually
exclusive like you can't have health
without spirituality you can't have
spirituality without Health right I mean
like they go together and so the trick
in like what is your Niche is like what
is the Andrea brand well it's about
what's on what's on top of that that
makes it all make sense so uh if you are
only talking about spirituality I no
connection to health and only talk about
health that no connection to
spirituality then those could live as
two separate YouTube channels and
products and Brands but one it's a lot
more work for someone like you to manage
right like now I got to manage two
social media accounts across everything
and it's also less of an expression of
who you are because you're always
limited by I can't talk about this stuff
because I'm only focused on X and so the
exercise that I like to go through with
people like what sits on top so if you
had to think who does you know what do
Andrea stain for that's
spirituality is part of it and health is
part of it and maybe something else is
part of it too but what sits above like
what what's the mother word where
spirituality and health are children how
do you create a business from all these
that you've been doing and then it
becomes something quite quite quite
quite REM
remarkable yeah I think there's lots of
ways to win I think it's more what do
you want to do so I like helping people
so I like I like doing courses but not
just a course but I like I like training
I like I like having somebody in front
of me I like not just here's this course
and I never have to see you again I like
seeing the person and coaching them and
guiding them even just before this I was
I was leading my community and it it
actually used to be a course but then I
stopped it as a course and turned it
into a membership because people were
using a course but I never got to see
them I didn't get the I didn't get to
see the results of what they were doing
and now I get meet people every week and
see what they're up to and how I can
help but that's that's not necessarily
the best way to do it it's what do you
love doing so you could sell courses you
can sell Consulting you can sell your
products you can sell your services you
can sell your books you can sell your
speaking you can sell your hosting like
there's so many things you could sell
what is that you actually want to sell
that you love doing but I think it's
really important that when you are
getting started that you actually think
about how can you turn this into a
business how can you so that you're not
just wasting time like I I could have
grown grown a lot faster in the early
days of my channel too if I thought
about it like a business and there were
less opportunities there are less ways
to do it compared to right now but a lot
of people just oh I just want to be
famous okay but how are we going to make
money doing the thing that you're
creating because if it's just a hobby
most people will probably quit if you
can't figure out a way to make money
most people will probably quit on the
thing and so it's like how do you you
have your purpose and your mission and I
love yes and inside of that how can we
start to make money as soon as possible
so that you can stay dedicated to it
I've had people who leave my channel
because I've made videos on Trump I made
videos on on Clinton the Clinton the
Trump one well the Trump one was one of
my favorites of yours as
well great I mean you're people are very
in their in their bias camps but I like
that some people are crossing over just
just the willingness to learn I think
that's how you actually solve problem
absolutely the guy who grew up thinking
black people were the nword and now was
willing to learn like now we're we're
changing perspectives we're getting
somewhere I didn't set out to try to
solve racism but now it's a little tiny
piece of of the solution absolutely I
love it so like somebody had
enough uh Equity or confidence in
me that they entire background growing
up with their parents and saying like
these people are the worst humans alive
and you can't anything from them but
Evan suggested that I watch his video
he's put up on his channel for a reason
that brief moment of confidence LED this
guy to watch the video and now he he
changes perspective um that's I'm proud
of that I'm happy that I did I'm proud
of myself for that even though I may
lose some people who who will say never
profile a black person on your channel
they got nothing to teach you that's
right like I'll lose those people okay
but maybe I'll convert some of them over
absolutely AB absolutely and it's very
common that this is part of my ninja
whole strategy behind the channel that's
evolved my ninja strategies people come
in who to find people who look like
them it it just is like like guys will
gravitate towards guys women towards
women Tech entrepreneurs towards Tech
all of it whoever's like you you want to
go and learn it's just natural yeah but
I want I want to have those people bring
you in and then introduce other people
who don't look like you who don't come
from the same industry or the same
background and challenge you to try to
learn from that person I think that's
where the real learning comes and I
think that's where tolerance and
understanding and patience is built what
do you sell like what's the main thing
that you want to
sell like um right now I have my books I
don't have many many other things maybe
I could come up with many other things
but now I have my books and I I am a
speaker so but I haven't been speaking
quite much I I am in Europe haven't been
much further on
out cool so anything that you want to
sell should be a series on your channel
so if you want to sell books then the
best thing to do is think about people
who can recommend your books and have
them as a guest on your
show so we're using the show for
business development so who can push a
lot of books and it might be
entrepreneurs it might be other
influencers it might be people from the
book Community it might be uh book
agents anybody in the book world people
with a big list that they might send it
to people who run book clubs right how
do you have them as guests on your show
and we we almost don't even care how
well the video does in terms of metrics
on YouTube Facebook whatever it's free
to build a relationship so that they get
to know you love you trust you and your
book becomes the next thing that they
use in their book club right if you made
a list of the top 500 book clubs in
America and then reached out to all of
those leaders who run the book clubs and
have them as guests on your show you're
gonna get a lot more people reading your
book oh okay being intentional a lot of
people tend to say put others before you
put yourself and for me I've always
thought that wasn't the necessary
correct way for me to operate I know
that when I put myself first when I take
care of my health and when I make sure
that I'm living in alignment with my
dreams I serve others better then versus
putting them first and then me suffering
and so for you has that been something
that's been natural to you I think it's
all learned
behavior uh I think my parents started
me off early with just how they lived
and and being an inspiration I think
humans are built to serve period like I
think if you're not happy in life it's
because you're not serving somebody
gotta and some people are built to serve
the world like chances are the two of us
we're built to serve we want to have a
big impact we want our our reach to be
wide we have a message that needs to be
heard yeah uh but some people are just
built to serve the 25 closest people to
them perfect my wife is more like that's
it she wants to she's still in contact
with her friends from kindergarten but
but doesn't have a message that she
wants to share with the world that's
right still buil to serve if you're not
happy because not you're not serving
others so the it's the same thing when
you're happy you're you're capable of
serving more people when you're growing
when you've taken another step on the
staircase you can pull more people up to
join you on that
step but if you're stay at the ground
level you can't you can only help people
with things you've gone through and
grown through right so the more you grow
and learn the more you can pull people
up and and help them and that's
ultimately what's going to like I said
your purpose come comes from your pain
the more you struggle and suffer and
then grow the more you'll be able to
help other people go through that same
thing so I see them as the same
thing investing in yourself and learning
getting better and struggling allows you
then to help others but it's based off
of a default premise that people are
good like I believe humans are good and
and that we're built to serve that's
amazing and that if somebody's doing
something that's negative or wrong or
insulting or imagine if you was assume
that so for example in La my car was
everything my car was stolen I was on my
I was on my tour um they stole my gear
my signs my wallet my phone like they
stole everything in the car giant
Suburban rated wow in a in a private
parking lot um I think those people are
good people who are built to serve like
whoever stole from my car they're good
people who are built the surf I just
believe that how do you balance your
your home life your work life what does
balance look like to you do you do you
have a routine can you tell us a little
bit about it yeah I think ultimately My
Philosophy is your actions have to map
to your Ambitions so what are your
Ambitions what do you want to create
what's the what's your perfect dream
life I think part of being an
entrepreneurs we get to pick what we do
I mean that's why we become
entrepreneurs we want to create the
schedule that we want for ourselves so
what is a dream life look like for you
and it's not going to be all day working
you don't want to spend all day work on
your business um you also don't want to
spend all day with your kids and you
don't want to spend all day with your
spouse so what does that balance and mix
look like for you and and that's a very
personal question I think part of where
we struggle is We compare Our Lives to
somebody else it's like oh well she's
such a super mom and she's doing all
these things and so I suck because I'm
not doing it like she's doing or like
he's doing it where this is a very
personal question and
so what I do is uh I have different
dates through different things so every
morning I'll start de with my morning
routine part of that includes if we're
talking family time part of that
includes me walking with my wife so this
morning we walked the Whole Foods we
took the dogs out it's starting to get
warm here in Toronto Canada which is
amazing uh grabbed the Americano from
Whole Foods walk back and just set up
our morning what are you working on
today what you know how is your sleep
just connecting grounding getting some
sun in our face getting some fresh air
hanging with the dogs like I like just
that connection in the morning to Nature
and to my my pets and my wife and you
know it's a half hour walk um and then
from there I'm mostly working like
today's been back to back to back calls
and podcasts and training and just work
work work work work work work uh I have
five minute gaps in between and my wife
works with me she's in the other room I
saw her outside on the balcony with the
dog so pop in say hi give her a kiss
come back like little micro moments like
that but for the most part it's just
work um and then different days
different different actions today's
we're filming this on a thir Thursday
that's my public facing day where it's
non-stop interviews and podcast we'll do
something every night to hang out I'll
spend some time um just with my wife
usually watching something relaxing with
the dogs on the couch kind of thing I'll
spend some time with my son uh often
like playing Minecraft or something fun
that he likes to do um and then that's
usually Monday to Friday weekends are
different story Saturday is funay and so
Saturday we always do something for the
family that's not not work related and
not uh admin related so we're not going
grocery shopping we're not doing uh you
know condo cleaning or house cleaning or
whatever but something something fun
like there's a street festival or we're
going to go for a hike outside or we're
going to try a new restaurant or just
something that we want to do and then
Sunday is family admin day where that's
all of the fold the laundry and clean up
the office and you know like whatever
you have to do to kind of
run oh I love this run run our lives
what is your
philosophy uh in terms of as you studied
all these people what do you think for
those listening what are some of the
core elements of success that would be
useful to our listeners if you will so I
think the the number one rule that comes
up consistently and we've we've covered
people who are I started just
entrepreneurs and we've expanded to
athletes and musicians and innovators
and politicians and like anybody who's
had success from any Walk of Life the
number one thing that it all that they
all have in common is the love for the
work that they're doing of yes loving
the the results but like loving the
actual
work often even when it doesn't make
sense for a lot of these people starting
up they have this passion for XYZ but
didn't make sense like there was no
business model attached to it I don't
know how it's going to work out and so
making the big decisions with the heart
and not the head you make the big
decisions with the heart and then use
your head to help figure out how you're
G to make it work is a consistent theme
across um all the people that we
profiled uh at some at some degree
you're going to have people who will
will hate on your idea will tell you
that it won't work especially the bigger
the idea you have the more people are
going to hate against it you know like a
lot of people would say TJ we don't have
greatness within us come on man like
what are you trying to do and like and
the bigger the mission you have the more
people fight because it's changed they
they want to protect the status quo and
so if nobody's hating on what you're
doing then you're not you're not
actually living a great life um in my
opinion you don't have an important
enough Mission and so
so expecting people to to hate on on
your ideas uh and then be able to deal
with it I think are some of the key
things that keep coming up over and over
and over and over again across all
successful people momentum is something
I've been talking about for years I
often say the biggest thing people are
missing is just momentum when I'm
helping entrepreneurs and I'm I'm
looking at people and yeah Scott I know
you've met a lot of people like this too
who've got like a great idea a huge
heart a desire to serve like a passion
to do good not not just make money but
to actually try to create something
meaningful it's like but why haven't you
started it's like the biggest thing
you're missing it just momentum is what
I would always say as a as a catchphrase
I guess just like let's go just stop
being afraid and just go and create and
so I actually wasn't planning on writing
another book my last book was built to
serve and if you had asked me at the
beginning of last year what's your book
it's built to serve when's the next book
it's not like it's built to serve that's
it and then I did an Instagram live with
um Kira who became a friend who then
became a uh became a business partner
with her in her publishing house and she
said she was a book medium when I met
her at genius Network and I said well
what's a book medium like well I help
people Channel their books like okay I
liked her vibe and her energy I had no
intention of writing the book but I said
hey why don't why don't we do it as an
Instagram live like what do you mean
come on my Instagram and you can
channnel my next book with me do your
thing with me right and like oh no no
it's usually private I don't do this as
a public thing okay just come on come on
we'll do it together it'll be fun so she
was nervous but she said yes and we
channeled my book and out of that came
the idea of
momentum
and then she said okay well when are you
going to write the
book well it's called momentum so it's
kind of hard to delay that right it's
kind of hard to say well and next year
I'll start right
it's like so I guess I'm starting today
and they ended up writing the book this
book so it's a it's like not a giant
book but it's not a little book either
in five days so I wrote the whole thing
in five days uh we then got it you know
cover printed all of the stuff that has
to go into publishing a book inside of
eight weeks it started with her
challenging me to write the book in
eight weeks and in context my first book
with penguin Random House took me a year
to write so even idea of writing the
book in eight weeks was already massive
uh time crunch because I didn't have
eight magical weeks just open in my
calendar like I've got my software
company running I've got my YouTube Team
running we've got 50 people on the team
you know like there's a lot of work that
has to get done now magically I have to
write a book as well and I just started
writing it was flowing out and I
actually got it done in five days and
said why don't we just get it published
in eight weeks instead of me having it
written in eight weeks and um yeah so
there it is momentum how do you get to
that level because there's so much noise
isn't there there's so many people
competing and people get this is a bit
of a long-winded question but people get
very disheartened because they don't get
immediate results so they say oh it
doesn't work so what would you say to
those
people well I I don't know if you've
seen my journey I post it on my website
so if anybody wants to see how how uh
slowly I took at the beginning to get
going uh people use it as inspiration um
I post every year so I started uh in
2009 and every may I post where where
I'm at in terms of my subscriber growth
and the first year was 25 subscribers
and the second year was like 100
subscribers something in my fifth year I
still had 700 subscribers or something
like that and that's like people will
say hi did you not quit like how do you
keep going how you're in year five and
you only have 700 something subscribers
like you might want to go find something
else you know it's like it's not working
go do something else uh so I I mean I
just I love doing it and I think that's
why you have to love the process of the
thing that you're doing and if anybody
people you know I challenge people to do
this because it's a fun thing but a lot
of times people will take take that
graphic of how I'm doing Year bye and
then they they U put it into an
Instagram post or video or tweet or
something to say that they're beating
Evan carmichel because most people are
beating me most people by year five you
know already have more than 700
something subscribers so you can say
that you're ahead of me the only
difference is I kept going you know I
just I just kept going I kept making it
I kept creating content I kept sharing
and when people ask well how did you
keep going like how did you not quit
what give you the inspiration and reason
to keep going I always focus on who I
was serving instead of who I
wasn't okay and that made a a huge shift
for me because we all most of us are in
the who I'm not serving game right even
now I've got three whatever million
subscribers why is it not four why is it
not five why is it not 10 you know what
the the who I'm not game is never ending
but who you are serving right now can
make all the difference in the world so
that those 25 people in my first year
like those are 25 people who subscribe
to my channel you know like that's
pretty cool I thought that was pretty
cool if you go and you speak at a at a
library or a YMCA or my first speaking
gig was at a YMCA and 25 people show up
that's pretty cool now I thought I would
think that's pretty cool my first
speaking I had three people show up so
if 25 people showed up that'd be pretty
cool and so if you can if you can
re-engineer your mind to to think about
that that hey if I have 25 people or 100
people or a thousand people or however
big your audience is it doesn't mean
that you stop growing and you get
complacent and you just only live in
gratitude for what you've got but if you
focus on serving them instead of who
you're not serving it does a couple
things one
it's a lot more fun you to feel like you
matter and that the work you're doing is
having an impact on people and that fun
we all want to feel like we're doing
something that matters and if you can
actually connect the thing that you're
you're doing actually matters to
somebody maybe not the world you and I
want to serve the world cool and if you
knew that you did something today that
helped at least one person it's easy to
have the motivation to keep going it and
doing it again the next day the next day
the next day and two the people who you
are serving will take you to the people
who you're not serving you know like if
you keep serving in your people well
they'll tell them they'll tell their
friends about you say hey go watch this
person's video um and you never know the
impact that you're you're having on
people what advice would you give to
folks who are listening to this who know
that they're destined for more and what
message would you like to leave them
with today just to know that it's
possible that whatever that dream in
your head is that it's actually probably
even small compared to what you're
capable of and that it's Poss
and that people with less intelligence
and less resources than you Your Heroes
a lot of them started with less than
what you have right now you have Steven
to pay attention to you know a lot of
your Heroes didn't have anybody and they
figured it out and so if they can you
can too and it requires a different way
of thinking it requires uh a different
way of acting it requires you maybe
saying no to some people and then saying
yes to new people and new opportunities
in your life but your dream is possible
and you just have to wake up every day
and take one more step towards making
momentum happen towards it because I
think for a lot of people the biggest
thing they're missing is just momentum
walk us through an average every day for
you as a high
performer well average every day or or
when I was on tour during 90 days t on
tour on tour on tour so part of the
reason for doing the tour was I was
afraid of speaking and i' done a lot of
speaking but it was always just like
uh you you speak and then it you're
scared and then I come back home and
then I'm fine and then you I was I I
wanted to get rid of this fear of
speaking and so I thought okay I'm just
going to go and do 23 cities and every
four days speak again every three four
days like a new new city do it again do
it again do it again do it again get my
reps in and that became the starting
point so every fourth day basically I
was in a new city speaking uh every
fourth day we also had to travel we
still had had to work uh and I wanted to
spend some time with nah it was me Nina
and my cameraman Danny for 90 days
together Hotel hopping Airbnb hopping it
was it was a pretty chaotic but fun ride
in what way did you get better and what
did you invest in so it was it was
mindset and skill set so in the mindset
I I'm introverted I'm shy that doesn't
come across on like interviews like this
but um I don't like the spotlight I
don't like being I don't like being on
stage um it makes me nervous I it's not
it's not enjoyable I just came back from
a 3-day event in Vegas where I was
speaking with with Gary Vee and um
Patrick mavid and other great speakers
on stage and I don't like being on stage
I like the effect it creates on the
hallway afterwards to go help people so
I'll I'm the only speaker who sticks
around and then I stay for hours in the
hallway talking to people um because
they'll come up to me and ask me
questions based off of my talk where
normally I would I wouldn't go up to
anybody and talk to them not because I'm
I'm too good for them but because I'm
afraid you know I'm introverted and shy
um but we still want to serve and so
that was that was a huge breakthrough
for me when I realized even though I'm
introverted and shy I still want to
serve I still want to help and all my
models at the time if you look at who's
on TV you just see the people who are
big mouth and extroverted in the life of
the party and like that wasn't me so I
thought oh like to do that you know I'm
at the same agency as M Robbins and
Grant Cardone and both of them very out
outwards focused and like the life of
the party and extrovert and love talking
to people um and just that wasn't me so
I I it took a while for me once I tied
it to service then it was an unlock it's
like it's not about me it's about the
people you can help and then that became
like oh okay but how does an introvert
make a lot of YouTube videos and win I
don't know but we'll just figure it out
you know like let's try let's see what
happens um and then the second part of
that was was getting help in
communication and getting once I decided
to take it more seriously that I
realized oh I should be doing more then
then um yeah just getting coaching and
getting help and watch my videos back
and becoming a better speaker um so
people can get there a lot faster it's
not like oh once you have a th
subscribers or 100,000 subscribers or a
million subscribers or whatever it is
then instantly everything gets better
it's much more about are you are you
good enough are you have the skill set
and the talent and the mindset to
make great content and obviously the
more repetition you put in the better
but but getting coaching and getting
help and getting people to give you
guidance um really helped me too on your
mission that you're on what challenges
with that format that you've built uh
have you faced for what's next and
what's been the advantage of that format
for what you've been able to build and
the impact that you're making in the
world my biggest limit ation is still
lack of
belief
so people say but you're the belief guy
it's like yeah but I believe in myself
to do the things that I've done now but
to do the next the next big thing I
don't believe in myself to do the next
big so I still need the channel for
myself because I want to wake up and
have Oprah Winfrey or Steve Jobs or Elon
Musk or whoever it is Whispering
messages in my ear to get me going to do
the next thing um one of my my
uh talk about the format of of giving
tribute to other people uh at the
beginning it was just hey I've learned
this from these people and I think you
might be able to learn too I was just
hoping to shortcut the path cuz my my
worst day in my first business was when
I said I quit on my business partner and
I woke up the next day and said I can't
quit yet because I'm going to regret
this if I don't figure this out at least
at least if it doesn't work out fine but
at least know that I gave it everything
cuz I don't want to look back and say ah
I wish I just tried a little bit harder
but I couldn't keep going the way that I
was going so I had to find another path
and the thing that came to me was I
can't be the first person to try to
solve this problem like somebody's
figured this out why don't I just model
success like that wasn't model success
wasn't words that I would use you know
it probably a lot more clumsy but I
can't be the first person to figure this
out somebody's done it and that's where
I studied Bill Gates like Bill Gates had
a like who's got a software company I
had a software companies who's got a
successful software company Bill Gates
came to mind like I this was not very
Advanced planning it's just top of Dome
uh so okay how did Microsoft get started
and how did he build like not so much
how did how does Bill Gates make an
extra million dollars now who cares but
like zero to one how do you do that and
it was through Partnerships and and
learning how he applied that in
Microsoft I brought that to my business
and quickly after had my first check for
$135,000 and that may not seem like a
lot but when you're making 300 bucks a
month like 13 12K it's like holy cow
this is a grand slim here and more
importantly I could do that again that
was just one deal I could close more
deals so the idea the strategy there was
model success find people who have done
this and put that to use in your
business or your life and so I I then
went on this mission to continue
learning how I can model other people
success and then I that eventually
became my YouTube channel where I shared
a lot of messages um a surprising
benefit of that has been I've gotten to
meet some of these people you know like
I was just profiling some of them and
then now I get to do interviews with
them or go hang out with them or go to
their houses and some of them become
friends which was never part of the idea
of what I could do it's just hey I love
your
message I'm trying to get it out to the
world because if I learn from it maybe
other people like me can learn from it
and it's been amazing to be able to
foster a lot of those connections too I
encourage entrepreneurs to go through
um a three-step process which is
eliminate automate delegate okay so you
look at the work that you're doing and
maybe you shouldn't be doing it at all
like before you give it to somebody else
maybe it just shouldn't get done and
there's there's often things that we're
doing that we think are really high
value that then turn out to like to not
matter and we may not even notice it
right I mean before Movie Makers I had a
mastermind that I ran in Toronto for
entrepreneurs and when people joined we
took uh minutes like notes of what was
happening like I took minutes this
before AI could do it for you and
transcripts like I wrote down minutes
for what everybody said and homework and
assignments and everything and um there
was one month where I forget what
happened like I was going away the next
day or something and I didn't get the
notes out to people after the meeting
nobody
cared like no response no message no
like Hey where's the minutes where's the
notes and I and so I didn't do it again
next month nobody cared it's like wow
I've been spending all this time on
something that like nobody cared about
that I thought was high value but was
actually zero value for people um maybe
it was even negative value maybe I was
annoying them with it I don't know uh
and so eliminate first you know so I
mean a lot of entrepreneurs might be
frustrated with their accounting and
bookkeeping uh you cannot eliminate that
right like that has to get done yeah you
run into problems if you try to
eliminate that from your business right
and I was going to go into that for you
but yeah keep going yeah the government
will come for you that is a big problem
unless you live in some country that
that doesn't move to the moon or
something but um yeah you know that's a
problem so you can't eliminate that but
but there's a lot of things that we're
doing that just should not be done they
just be completely eliminated the next
is automate so before giving it to a
human give it to technology so use
software use tools use AI use QuickBooks
use like there's a lot of things there's
software and tools for a lot of things
that you should should start applying
into your
business uh that can save a lot of man
hours um and then you get to delegate so
eliminate automate and then delegate and
so these are the things that still have
to get done but should not be done by
you so in eliminate they shouldn't be
done at all in automate they need to be
done but should be done by a human and
then in delegate it's it it should be
done but shouldn't be done by you has to
be done by another human and that's
where you start to scale and build and
create if you're trying to get your
journey going on YouTube cool take a
bite and see try making videos try doing
Vlogs try doing interviews try doing
direct the camera try doing speeches try
the things that you see and expect to
suck at all of them at the beginning
you're not going to be good because you
don't have the skill set yet doesn't
mean you suck as a human you just you
don't have the skill set yet but the
thing to pay attention to is did you
enjoy it how did you feel after doing it
you had that interview and it's easy to
go back if you go back and watch your
first interview it's a train wack it
mean you're awkward and nervous and ask
the wrong questions and you can look
back on it and say oh my gosh I should
have done that and you can go over it in
your head a million times but like but
did you like it you know like was it fun
to do do you want to go back and do it
again did it give you more energy than
it took and if it's a yes then that's a
great sign to keep
going and so a lot of people stop on
YouTube because they don't get immediate
results because they're not doing
something that they feels authentic to
them um and they're focused on who
they're not serving instead of who they
are serving um and they just judge
themselves too harshly for not having
the skill set yet like you don't just
get on a snowboard and go down the hill
you fall 80 times on your first run and
then you fall 50 times on your second
run right and you just you get better as
you go do you think that for people who
are looking at making an impact whether
that be online or through content or
speaking or any of those different
Avenues where do you see that kind of
the next Horizon kind of like you
entered YouTube very early on what do
you think's next so I think it depends
on what your mission is right so for me
I've got a giant mission right I want to
impact the whole world and so how do you
do that well my hypothesis is that it's
content at
scale and if you're going to do content
at scale you've got two options long
form or short form like the platforms
are basically divided take Tok and snap
and Facebook and Instagram are all short
form content and then YouTube is long
form and YouTube has shorts I guess is a
combination but there's YouTube on one
side with the long form and all the
other content which is short form and if
if you want to have an impact and really
want to make a difference I I think it's
hard to do it in 30 second little Clips
so that's a lot more inspiring but it's
not really making a huge impact if
you're trying to explain multif family
investing in a 42 second video like good
luck right so so but it's fine like the
shorts have their own path it's to
inspire but it's not really to to do
deep education and you're not really
doing any of the deep work just from the
clips so hopefully the clips Inspire
somebody to start down the path to learn
more about this thing talk to me a
little bit about the service mentality
and that service above self mentality
that I mentioned because I feel like
it's really um a part of your core it's
something that you really really
authenticate so I haven't heard of uh
service above self before but I'm also
not part of rotary and um I think
ultimately service is the path to self I
think I think humans are built to serve
I think if you're not happy it's because
you're not
serving every day we all want to wake up
and feel like what we do matters to
somebody else we we want to feel like
the job we're going to or the business
we're creating or whatever we're going
to do today is going to have an impact
on somebody else and some people you and
I and probably most of your listeners we
want to change the world we want to have
a big impact we want to go and you know
have our message reach wide and far but
not because of us but because of the
impact that we want to create and other
people like my wife
Nina she doesn't want to have a big
mission but she serves the 25 closest
people to us she's the glue for our
family remember everybody's birthdays
and what they're doing and what they
need and what they're going through and
all of the stuff that I forget and
probably I should get better at but
everybody wants to
serve serving others is hardwired into
our brain they did functional MRIs on
people's brains and found that serving
other people hits the same part of your
brain as having food and having sex so
it's like literally hardwired into your
brain that you need this to be a
functioning happy member of society I
think some people um have experienced
things like act of kindness you know how
nice it is to buy the coffee with the
person behind you in line or hold the
door or those kinds of things and those
moments are great and keep doing them
but I think everybody also has a much
deeper level of service where I believe
that your purpose comes from your pain
that whatever you struggled the most
with as a human is what you want to help
other people through and so when you can
see somebody who is going through the
thing that you went through and feels
hopeless and lost and is struggling and
doesn't see a way out and then they
spend eight minutes with you you say hey
you know what it's okay it's like I went
through that too and here's how to get
out and then you see hope in their eyes
for the first time and like you made
that happen you caused that and then
that's that little that's a that's a
spark in their life that can change the
entire trajectory of their life that's
the thing to get addicted to like that's
what we all want want and I think we're
living in a world now where a lot of
people find zero meaning in their work
they're driving to a job that they hate
and I'm just trying to ignite some
passion in
people tell me about your daily
routine so I have a morning routine and
an evening routine that are fairly
consistent and then I have a daily
routine that's different than other days
so so one day a week to do different
things terms of that kind of daily
routine that switches
up um switching costs are real you know
even even in monotasking like we know
multitasking of of trying to do multiple
things at once but even monotasking to
do one thing at a time switching costs
are huge between jumping from one thing
to another so if I'm going to jump from
you to then go and write my book to then
going and doing email to then go it's
just it's too much of a switch you know
for me to get into the zone of writing
my book I need 45 minutes just to get
back to where I was from the last time I
left off from it so I try to assign
different things for different dat
now I'm I'm in complete control pretty
much of my calendar that mean that'd be
the case for everybody but for what you
can control then being intentional about
it so for me monay Monday is my
mentoring day we have 40 people on my
team I want to be the kind of boss that
when they come in we make them a better
human than if they ever leave right so I
spend the whole day mentoring the people
on my team Tuesday is my YouTube day
it's content day I'm filming like if you
do not have time in your calendar to
film you're not going to film you're not
going to make the content if you wait
till you're inspired you're never going
to make anything so Tuesday is like
YouTube it's consistent it's in my
calendar every Tuesday I'm making
content Wednesday is my project day and
that is free it's open it's whatever I
want to work on because the over
scheduled entrepreneur usually ends up
hating their life or their business
because they never have time to work on
the things that that is new into their
company so my Tuesdays and Thursdays are
really jam-packed Wednesday in the
middle is completely open so yesterday
was a Wednesday I'm working on my book
next Wednesday I might work on something
completely different different and it
doesn't always have to have a practical
payoff it's just something new fun exper
creativity is messy so Wednesday is a
messy day Thursday is my public facing
day interviews podcast today's a
Thursday when we're recording this right
right so when we book these you know I
25 minutes on five minute break 25
minutes on five minute break so after
this I'm going into another 25 minute
session then a five minute break and
it's like my whole day gets filled up
doing other people's shows and podcast
and it's it it's just staying in the
same energy like the energy you're
getting now I'm natur introverted and
people don't get that about me it
doesn't come across but the energy I'm
showing up for your show is the result
of the five other shows I've done before
getting to you right and I'm GNA then
take Ashish energy and pour it into the
next person right so this you're you're
not um sucking my energy you're feeding
me energy that I'm then going to pour
into the person who comes afterwards
right so like staying in that energy
zone is really important that's how the
day flies by and you get into flow
instead of having to jump from one thing
to the next Friday's my CEO day um and I
start started with CEO hours like if I
had one hour what would I do if I was a
CEO like whatever that means to you
you're the CEO of your business now what
does that person do and I moved it to be
the whole day so like working on the
business instead of in the business uh
and then apply to the weekend like
Saturday's Funday Saturday is fun stuff
to do with my wife with the family not
like we just got a new house and there's
insane amounts of work that has to get
done but that's not Saturday Saturday is
what we're going to do for fun new
restaurant Street Festival drive-in
movie theater hang out like whatever but
fun and then Sunday's family admin day
where that's
the getting ready for ex going to Costco
and doing the laundry and whatever and
then and then it repeats again on Monday
and like that your you know your actions
have to map to your amb missions you
have you have goals of what you want to
accomplish and not just like business
goals but a life what do you what do you
want to what does your dream life look
like and then you have to have it in
your calendar to do the actions other
otherwise it just becomes you know a
hope so that's my yeah that's my I love
my life design man it's all design and
it'll change and switch right like when
it changes at the beginning I had nobody
on my team so I didn't have a a
mentoring day who was a mentoring nobody
so let get to work now I have 40 people
on my team so I need to have a day
focused on mentoring and so the
willingness this is like the willingness
to Pivot and change especially in
entrepreneurship because you learn and
grow right like entrepreneurship is the
greatest personal development course of
all time you're learning and growing and
improving so it's crazy to think that
how you start and what you're working on
now is still going to be the same thing
in 3 years like your business has to
Pivot and change and your calendar has
to Pivot and change as you change and
evolve as a human being so wherever I'm
not happy especially consistently like
if it's a couple days in a row of not
being happy something is wrong in my
calendar like I'm just not doing the
right things anymore and I need to make
a change and if you can catch it early
enough then you don't end up having this
giant crisis where you have to make this
insane change right because you feel you
just fell completely out of alignment
with yourself I think you have to trust
your gut that's what they say yeah
because opportunities are coming like
that all the time but the problem is
they don't make sense a lot of
times because that shouldn't be coming
to you or or you're not qualified or why
am I thinking about that or I didn't go
to school for that or that's not what I
should be doing
right and so we're missing all these
opportunities every day that are coming
by so you might there might be some
person walking down the street and for
whatever thought in your head I should I
should say hi to them why would I do
that I don't say hi to people I'm in I'm
shy I don't talk to people right it's
like okay how you doing
I'm and and you say you're inter no but
like but that doesn't no no but I don't
do that that often but if I had the idea
for then I would right so it's it's just
I've had to train myself to just not
think about my thoughts and just do it
and just do it trust Robins 54321 even
faster than that right like trust that
great ideas flow through
you no want give that
shot now the caveat is if you're in a
really negative mood that's where you
need patience right like if somebody
cuts you off in traffic oh yeah I'm
going to drive past that guy just to see
what he looks like right you
know but that's that's where we trust
our impulses we will trust our impulses
when we're in a really negative state of
mind but when we're in a really positive
one that's where we pause and we need to
flip it when you're in a really negative
State of Mind some bad news happened
don't make a a a a rash call in the
moment right like something negative
happened the whole world is not falling
apart pause reflect sleep on it like
come back to it the next day and still
see if you want to do that thing or not
but when something great is happening
and you're in a positive spirit and an
idea comes to you that's the time not
you go do something about it people are
watching this episode and like I want to
go do blank do it now because you're
going to wake up tomorrow and the energy
will be gone and you're starting over
again and the opportunity will pass you
by when did you start the habit of
replacing those negative thoughts with
positive ones and then when did you
start to see them take root and actually
manifest in your life I don't know that
I made a conscious choice that like now
I'm going to replace this with this
thought I think it's just as a result of
being in the industry so long watching
so many like if you think about what I
do and how many videos I watch of how
many successful people they all have
some core themes to them and whether
it's entrepreneurs or athletes or
artists or musicians or whoever they
have similar themes and and you know
turning lemonade or turning lemons into
lemonade you know turning a negative
into a positive is is a consistent theme
across everybody and so I think it just
it happened
subconsciously just by being in the
environment of having those people
around me virtually to the point where I
was doing that exercise being forced to
sit with negative thoughts and it it I
had changed but I didn't notice like I
don't there was no moment of coming out
of the Cocoon and now I'm a butterfly it
just slowly became here I am as a
butterfly gotcha so it was just going
through the process yeah
it's it's like imagine if you were
working out your legs every day you
don't you don't you don't see a daytoday
difference right there's no one moment
like oh you did one extra hard set and
now you've got these Rippling calves
ready to go right but I think the only
difference was I wasn't
even consciously training it was just
because it was in my environment and I
think that happens for a lot I think
that happens for most people just in a
negative way you're constantly watching
news and Twitter streams and all of this
negativity and all of a sudden you know
you start to become a negative person
because of all the things that are
happening around you but it's not that
you can pinpoint one thing that that was
the moment you became negative or even
notice that you're becoming negative is
just happening and so that's the power
of when you shift your environment and
you're controlling what you're consuming
into your you know into your brain so I
was conscious of what I was consuming I
wasn't conscious about a lot of the
transformation that happened as a result
it's only in looking back or doing
exercises like that
um that I notice the difference I
mentioned grief as a caveat because
that's the only one that I don't think
you can you can just positive your way
out of sure you know like I think you
just have to feel your way through grief
at least me you know I have I haven't
lost my parents so that's awesome but um
my family dog was like that was the only
time I haven't made videos in the past
10 years was when my family dog passed
away wow uh because he died on filming
day and I just couldn't film
and I I could have if it was anything
else if I was jealous if it was angry if
I got cut off on traffic if I lost a
bunch of subscribers I don't know
something else happened like okay come
on let's go car like film but I just
didn't feel right to push past it to
film you know like I film with a
concussion and a broken neck and all
this other stuff but when when Toby
passed like I don't know it doesn't feel
right to just rush it away and so I just
have to feel this because you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you are
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you you are awesome and if
you want to watch Evan's top 10 rules
for Success check out the video next to
me I think you can enjoy continue to
believe I will see you there if you're
just chasing what's hot but you have no
interest in it you're never going to win
cuz you're going up against people who
absolutely love the thing it's in that
intersection of what you love doing with
what there's a market for what about all
the things